members take your
seats
are we doing a
traditional
members take your
seats speaker
e
ready
how come to
order chair recognize a member from
Auburn representative Osborne who whoes
the house adjourn from the session of
February 8th 2024 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay the eyes have house is
adjourned house will attend to a Prayer
by house chaplain and Reverend Bob
Stewart patri St Paul's and Methodist
Church of
Manchester
good afternoon New Hampshire House of
Representatives good afternoon Mr
Speaker good afternoon
God let us pause for a moment of silence
as reme we remember our friend and
colleague representative Sharon nordgren
who represented Handover New Hampshire
for the last 18
terms let us pause for a
moment oh god of us
all your love never
ends when all else fails you still are
God we know that Sharon is at
peace and has taken her place that has
been prepared for
her help all who mourn to also find your
peace this
day oh compassion and
God there is so much hate in this
world we see the hate through
threatening letters sent through the
mail we see hate when people use a
weapon to kill or to cause injury to
others we see hate when others harm
others when everyone is celebrating a
victory we pray for the people in Kansas
City oh God often we hear and see so
much hate in this world that we begin to
live in fear and we begin to lose
hope we know God that you are our refuge
and our
strength always ready to help in times
of trouble Psalm 46 verse
1 give us the strength to not lose hope
and to use our ability to change things
in this world in our nation and in our
great state of New
Hampshire through this legislative body
we can make changes that can be positive
and beneficial to the people we
represent in the areas in which we
serve God give us your refuge and
strength to make wise
decisions help us to be your conduit in
this world of hate so that through each
of us we can share your love to everyone
we
meet one person at a
time oh god of love and
compassion I ask once again to be with
all the representatives and leaders that
are gathered here
today bless them oh God help them in
their decision making and help them to
feel that you are their refuge and their
strength as they conduct their business
today I pray for your peace and love to
come upon them this day and every day oh
God we give you the glory and praise for
you are our refuge and our
strength
amen
chair recognize as a member from Newport
representative skip Rollins who will now
lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance I to flag of the United
States of
America
stands
indivisible andice for
all the chair recognizes is
shelene Sasha a student from marac high
school who will now sing our national
anthem oh say can you
see by the dawn early
light what so
proudly we
held at the
Twilight last gleam in whose broad
stripes and bright
stars through the
PA
fight or the ramp parts we watched were
so
gallantly
streaming and the
rocket red
glare the boms
bursting in
air gave proof through the
night that our flag was still
there oh s do that star
spangled
B
wave or the
land of the
free and the
home of the
[Music]
[Applause]
braak
the house attend to request for leaves
of absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives pamon Jeffrey Smith in
11 the day important business
Representatives Cole foot Kenny
Katherine Kenny excuse me Mills nutting
smart trottier and Vincent the day
illness in the family Representatives MC
Beth and sandborne these leades of
absent shall be granted L otherwise
ordered by the house house will attend
to the introduction of guests Mr Speaker
please welcome Tierney and Charles Sara
parents of the singer guests of
Representative McHugh Charlie Post
husband of Representative Lisa post Sam
Co son of Representative Baldwin and
Alexis Eden guest of Representative
Heath Howard they're with us in the
gallery today Welcome to the New
Hampshire
[Applause]
house
the house will attend to a communication
Mr Speaker in an email dated February
9th
2024 uh resignation uh I wish to resign
my state house seat thank you Dan
Hines chair recognizes a
clerk the house will now attend to a
memorial resolution
house recognizes a
clerk Mr Speaker house resolution
33 whereas we have learned with profound
sorrow of the death of our friend and
colleague Sharon L nordgren who is
serving her 18th term as a state
representative representing the citizens
of Grafton County District 12 the towns
of Hanover and line and whereas Sharon
nordgren served in house leadership
numerous times including six years as
the deputy Democratic leader and Beyond
her service to the House of
Representatives Sharon nordd Ser served
her beloved town of hover on the select
board for nine years six as its
chair whereas Sharon nordri served on
the finance committee and its precursor
Appropriations 13 times including as
division chair and vice chair of the
committee and was widely regarded as an
expert on Health and Human Services in
the
committee and whereas a lover of travel
Sharon nordgren relished being out and
about learning new things about where
she was visiting and the people she was
meeting and recently visited England
with her whole family visiting
Stonehenge and speaking glowingly of the
local and the company and whereas above
all Sharon nordgren was a devoted wife
mother and grandmother and among her
greatest Joys was being an equestrian
mom now therefore beat resolved by the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
in regular session convened sharonelle
nordgren be granted the highest praise
and accolades and our profound thanks
for her service to her State and the
town she adopted as home for many years
and be it further resolved that
expressions of our most heartfelt
sympathy be extended to her family and
that a suitable copy of this resolution
be prepared for presentation to
them please rise and join me in a moment
of silence in honor of representative
from Hanover The Honorable Sharon
norren
house will attend to a resolution Mr
Speaker Representatives Osborne and
Wilhelm offer the following resolved
that the House of Representatives notify
the honorable Senate that it is ready to
meet in joint convention for the purpose
of hearing the State of the State
addressed by his Excellency the governor
Christopher T
senu the question is on the resolution
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the resolution is
adopted
for
e
she
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the Senate is ready to meet with the
honorable house and Joint convention for
the purpose of hearing the state of the
streight address by his Excellency
Governor Christopher
tunu chair recognizes the clerk not
ready
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
The Honorable
[Applause]
Senate
h
clerk chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker the president of the Senate The
Honorable Jeb Bradley of wolf
[Applause]
burrow the joined
convention
chair recognizes the
clerk Mr Speaker the New Hampshire State
Treasurer The Honorable Monica
mipel
Mr Speaker the New Hampshire Secretary
of State The Honorable David M
[Applause]
scanland Mr Speaker The Honorable New
Hampshire Supreme
Court
Mr Speaker the Chief Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court The Honorable
Gordon J
McDonald's Mr Speaker The Honorable
executive
counsel
Mr Speaker his Excellency the governor
Christopher
tsunu
Bud sir
[Applause]
are oh is it oh okay we're on great
thank
you can they sit down oh yeah I thought
so I told him to go first The Joint
convention will now come to
order
okay seven years we we'll get it right
eventually okay good afternoon good
great to see everybody here um great to
be back
uh so to kick things
off got my water Mr Speaker uh Mr Senate
President uh to The Honorable members of
the house and the Senate uh the
executive council members that are
joining us today our illustrious
Commissioners and of course uh the
members of the Supreme Court uh all very
exciting thank you guys for joining us
and obviously all the citizens that are
joining us both in Chambers and on
television today
welcome uh I was reminded earlier this
week that this was my final state of the
address I don't know if that was said in
with sadness or excitement I can't tell
fourth term don't care
um hey although the filing period to run
isn't until June so you never
know just just
kidding councelor warmington just almost
fell out of her chair right
there just kidding CD you're good uh no
as they say Eight is Enough right uh so
in that spirit I will do my best to be
brief but you know me I tend to ramble a
little bit um so as always I really do
enjoy taking this opportunity uh to uh
really be proud uh of the many
accomplishments that our state its
citizens and its and our communities
have delivered uh I think today you're
going to hear many proud data points and
proud rankings that we have achieved
together but through all those accolades
uh let us not forget that while immense
progress has been made in areas like
mental health education the opioid uh
pandemic uh we mustn't be blind to the
many families and citizens of our great
state still waiting for services or
struggling to meet ends meat struggling
to make ends meet let us not forget that
one of our fellow state employees went
to work in November but he never got to
come home to his family because he gave
his life protecting those around him at
New Hampshire hospital Chief Bradley hos
was a true hero we will never forget him
and we'll never stop being grateful for
his
bravery our pats on the back today so to
say say they're they're not going to
bring bad Bradley back they also won't
bring opportunities to families any
faster but my hope is that it will give
them confidence that New Hampshire has
the right approach and the attention to
individuals we're always willing to go
the extra mile to be Innovative in
providing opportunities to everyone so
let's start with everyone's favorite
topic politics he said to a room of
politicians so less than a month ago uh
our nation once again turned its eyes
towards New Hampshire just as we have
for the last last 100 years we hosted
the first in the nation presidential
primer now our place at the front of the
nomination calendar is never a given it
is always fought for earned and won we
take our responsibility of getting the
process right uh we take it very serious
and this year was no exception
candidates can come here with little
money or No Name ID they can campaign
the New Hampshire Way by going door
to-door town hall to town hall living
room to living room taking every
question and being accountable to the
voters not just party bosses down in
Washington and I would like to extend a
great uh a great debt of gratitude to
the work of Secretary of State Dave
scandin his team and the countless City
and town election officials uh many of
which are volunteers by the way that
really made sure that this went off
without a hitch we all thank you
really
oh there he
[Applause]
[Music]
is so New Hampshire was a banner uh 2023
was a banner year for New Hampshire uh
we had opportunities and we achieved an
advancing Freedom we increased uh
opportunities in our economies we put
our families first and now you may have
heard some of these data points before
cuz I do like like to brag about them
and in other speeches but in just the
last year New Hampshire was rent the
number one state for overall Freedom the
number one state for economic freedom
the number one state for child
well-being and we will continue working
to ensure that we maintain the lowest
poverty rate in the country great job
really great
job so those are some of the big
headline ones some folks may have seen
those before but there are a few
rankings that maybe went under the radar
but I do want to acknowledge did you
know that this past year for the first
time ever our correction system was
ranked the best in the country so hats
off to commissioner Hanks great
job or did you know that New Hampshire
was the first state in the nation with a
nationally approved cyber security plan
uh nothing uh not an easy task and
something that is on the Forefront of
everything we do nowadays so again great
job to commissioner Dennis goule
New Hampshire is now ranked as the best
return on investment for taxpayers
number one I like to call that the
efficient government award so again
living a to a gold standard for the rest
of the
country here's one New Hampshire in two
separate reports New Hampshire is now
ranked as having both the smartest and
one of the most productive workforces in
the country a Real Testament to our
citizens and that is a big part of why
businesses are coming here from all over
the
country and I would be remiss I don't
know I'd be remiss I'm looking for him
somewhere uh if I didn't give a little
shout out to commissioner Bill Cass and
his amazing team at the Department of
Transportation uh not only are they
doing a great job plowing our road well
this year they're getting off a little
easy on the plow the roads and they are
great don't get me wrong they're great
mother nature's been very kind but again
for the first time ever uh New Hampshire
has been listed in one of the reports as
having the best roads in America so
great job bill
[Applause]
I don't I don't think it means we don't
have any potholes but ours I guess are
more pleasant than most I don't
know um so look we could keep going on
with a lot of these accolades but uh we
we would be here all day um I know
you're all getting anxious to get back
to work um so we don't want to take the
successes for granted right because
continued success is not inevitable we
must continually challenge ourselves
putting individuals before the system to
strive to be better stewards of tax pair
dollars and more accountable to the
people of the
state being the best is earned it is not
given and that is what has guided us
this last 7 years and that is what will
take us into more successes into the
future so I still believe with all these
great rankings one of the greatest
achievements and I really believe this
sincerely one of the greatest
achievements that we have had and
conquered was the passage of last year's
bipartisan balanced budget with an
evenly divided legislature on a on a
Voice vote and that is just an amazing
Testament to this body to the folks that
work tirelessly in the state house um uh
it didn't come with any gimmicks or
empty promises it was achieved with a
lot of hard work and so that is my
personal thanks on behalf of the 1.4
million constituents of this state to
say again thank you great job job well
done and that wasn't any small budget
there is a lot to be proud of that you
guys were able to achieve in that budget
it ensured an eighth straight year in
New Hampshire with no new taxes the full
elimination of the interest in dividends
tax historic increases historic
increases in Medicaid rates to help
retain our Healthcare Workforce on
across theboard pay raise again historic
pay raise for our uh vital state
employees at 12% we cut red tape we
simplified the professional lure process
for so many of our citizens across the
state you added $50 million uh to
promote and Achieve housing more Housing
Development which we know is one of the
number one issues uh across New
Hampshire and the one I love the most
after Decades of inaction we
reconstructed the education funding
formula ensuring efficiency fairness and
adding hundreds of millions of dollars
for the students of the state it it is a
really an amazing
job New Hampshire leads from the front
we do not follow that has been tried and
true for a couple hundred years now so
every policy Victory every economic win
and record breaking statistic has been
the direct result of that hard work
fiscal discipline sound government
stewardship and we should all be proud
and that in itself is the New Hampshire
success story today New Hampshire is
more prosperous than ever our economy
was ranked as the fastest growing in the
country last year at 8.1% becoming the
Envy the nation and the best place in
America to live work and raise a family
businesses are moving here in droves
after years of more people leaving the
state I think I think through 20 2015 we
had something like six straight years of
more people leaving the state than
moving in since 2015 we've had a surge
of domestic migration into New Hampshire
resulting more in more people working
than ever before nearly 40,000 more
people are working in New Hampshire
today than when I first took office and
our unemployment rate continues to be
one of the lowest in the
nation but if you are out there and I'm
sure there are folks listening out there
today that for whatever Reon reason they
could be having trouble finding a job
that's right for them or their family I
really encourage folks sincerely to
contact the Department of Employment
Security uh you know we have a great
commissioner over there commissioner
katus I hey George you here where's
George he's in the back smiling with
that funky mustache as
always you know if you don't know George
is a Cowboys fan so he kind of Lives In
Perpetual misery um but he takes amazing
pride and amazing joy and happiness in
working Within individuals finding them
a job finding the best career path for
their family so if anyone is struggling
give George and his team a call and I
really mean that sincerely they do an
amazing job we have 10 over 10,000 great
available jobs today and we want folks
to find the path that best fits them and
their family so definitely reach out um
congratulations commissioner cratus in
all sincerity your team has done a
tremendous tremendous
job so with all these successes
obviously they come challenges as well
there's no doubt about it businesses
cannot be successful without Workforce
and there won't be a Workforce unless we
have the housing this is something we've
really felt the burden of all across the
country but here in New Hampshire is no
exception uh for the past couple of
years families and work workers are the
backbone of a strong thriving State and
without housing our Economic Opportunity
suffers which is why with your support
we are able to launch our invest New
Hampshire invest NH housing fund a first
ofit kind fund to incentivize the
construction of new housing projects
this was just a couple years ago and the
goal was to get permits out and houses
up then the initial results are in in
this past month and it has been an
immediate success since launching the
program two short years ago the total
number of permits issued for residential
construction has doubled our
expectations in just this past year more
permits issued in more than a decade and
we're now on track to bring thousands of
new units online by all through 2024 so
already we have uh under the invest in h
fund we have housing developments that
have been completed in conquered in
Conway Manchester Lebanon Littleton um
almost all of which is Workforce housing
which is exactly what the state's need
it's a win for New Hampshire and again I
thank the legislature for making it all
happen so let's take a step back a
little bit and we can discuss some of
our Landmark strides in uh in the few
years surrounding opportunities around
kids and education obviously a Paramount
discussion that we continually have in
conquered now we can go back to the days
when the balance of our education trust
fund was negative by about $52 million
and if you were in the four walls of
that traditional classroom and it wasn't
working for your kid you were stuck you
were out of luck but that is not where
we are today not anymore next year the
education Surplus is expected to reach
over $230 million and families are
singing the Praises of the work done
right here in conquer for finally
passing the education Freedom accounts
which are now is the most effective and
popular school choice program in America
[Applause]
[Music]
and and why passing HB 1665 to expand
this opportunity for our families is so
vitally important let's get that
[Music]
done
[Applause]
[Music]
and today understand that today our
public schools are ranked number two in
the country we have amazing public
schools here in New Hampshire we have
amazing teachers doing amazing work with
our kids we now spend more dollars per
child than ever before in public
education all factors that allow kids to
maximize their potential through the
past few years we've instilled full day
kindergarten a huge win the learn
everywhere program allowing flexibility
for kids to get credits outside of the
classroom New Hampshire career academ is
where you can actually at no cost to the
individual or the state you can actually
get your Associates Degree for free as a
high school student amazing
opportunities that didn't exist just a
few years ago uh the one I'm most proud
of and and very excited about is this
year we have kind of our first of its
kind robotics fund it Sparks individual
opportunities for kids in the area of
stem and I'm going to take a quick
moment uh this this is a quick story
that happened just last week we became
the first state where I said look we're
going to put a robot in every classroom
right people said well that's crazy how
you going to do it and you did it you
really did but here's the interesting
part we didn't just say we're going to
put robots in every classroom and allow
this opportunity buy some robots and
ship them to the schools that's not what
we did at all um the the new first
robotics xrp robots they're now shipping
out but this is the way they did it
which I thought was really cool we're
the students are making the robots not
assembling them they literally are
building them in the 3D uh print Farms
right so the students are kind of
vertically integrating what they're
doing they're building the parts to the
robot they're getting involved with
supply chain and Manufacturing they're
putting them in their packages this is a
combination of high school students
working with the community colleges and
then they send them to other students in
the state to learn how to use them well
at the same time the teachers have a
free opportunity to take classes to
learn how to teach to them and at the
same time you all passed an opportunity
to give incentive bonuses to any school
teacher in the state that wants to
become a computer science teacher it's
so vertically integrated but I'm telling
you what you guys did is amazing this is
the future it's opening up all these
opportunities of Technology not just for
a few students but for every student and
not just for a few teachers but for
every teacher for everyone to
participate in that opportunity this is
where Workforce is going this is the
opportunity that we can give kids for
real world skills um and again not just
in their senior or junior year but up
and down for every single classroom so I
thought that was an amazing uh program
Dean came in and and his folks are
working again in conjunction with the
community colleges and the and the high
schools um when I went to this 3D print
farm and there were literally like you
know 40 different printers printing
these pieces um really taking it from
the supply chain all the way to seeing a
kid in that classroom using that that
device I thought it was amazing example
of making sure that kids have an
experiential something something
learning and experiential at every step
of the process it was
great now there's one more aspect of
Education I do want to touch upon
earlier this year um I created a special
task force to look at uh kind of a new
21st century model for post-secondary
Education uh I've asked the community
colleges in the University system some
folks in the business World some some
folks in the public sector uh to really
consider where the models for these
opportunities are headed it is changing
drastically when you become 17 18 years
old it isn't just we're going to apply
to some schools and go there's so many
there's such a host of opportunities
especially in this post-pandemic world
more online opportunities whatever it
might be so we've really challenged them
to look at what's happening uh
throughout that process and make sure
that we're staying ahead of that curve
and if we don't if we just kind of
whistle past the graveyard we're going
to see declining enrollments and we'll
really be scrambling in a crisis now at
the the same time I do want to I'd be
remiss if I didn't give out a shout out
and I thank you uh University of New
Hampshire uh is we have a great
president in James Dean I think he's
done a fantastic job over there he is
retiring so we'll be bringing somebody
in uh new on that level so that's we
thank Jim for uh James for his service
uh but there's opportunity there as well
and it's not just combining the systems
or what it might be but really making
sure we're looking at those college and
Community College opportunities from the
customer perspective I'm passionate
about it because I'm starting to tour
colleges with my own daughter right and
try try to see what what her is and so
as a as a constituent as as a consumer
if you will we're going through this as
the family in terms of what all the
options are uh the traditional models of
college and and Community College don't
work for everyone anymore but I think if
we stay ahead of it we I think we have a
a great opportunity with this task force
and I'm excited to see uh what they'll
what they'll be bringing us to ensure
that New Hampshire remains competitive
um and while I'm on the subject of of
colleges and post-secondary education
you know one of the or one of the
institutions uh I we don't often
recognize uh here in conquer uh they're
a private institution but a great
institution is the great work done by
Dartmouth College so let's take a little
bit of a step back we have seen all
across the country a lot of this growing
hateful anti anti-semitic rhetoric
across some of America's great college
campuses and frankly I I personally
think that the actions of many of the
Ivy League schools in America as it
pertains to this crisis I think it's
been terrible I've even for some of the
presidents of the Ivy Leagues to resign
but I want to very much applaud the
efforts of President Cen belock uh the
new president over at Dartmouth in just
her first year she has set Dartmouth
apart and led as an example of ensuring
free spe free speech and respect on
campus uh and guess what I mean she used
the situation to bring students together
and make sure it was an educational
process an educational form to learn on
this issue and those students have very
much responded in kind the rest of the
ivy league schol schools are now looking
as at Dartmouth as the example to follow
and I just want to take the opportunity
to thank her and her team for
representing New Hampshire so
[Music]
well changing gears a little bit you
know I go back to when I first got
elected even during the campaign one
thing I said a lot was that mental
health mental health was the unspoken
crisis of the time it was ignored the
system was absolutely fractured but with
a lot of the new funding that this
legislature has moved forward the
revamped programs an emphasis on
prioritizing people over bureaucracy we
have turned the tide now we're finally
giving families a sense that in their
toughest times there is a system that
can be focused on some better Solutions
thousands of New Hampshire families
today are struggling with mental health
issues in a variety of forms so why is
there good cause for Hope knowing that
you can have so many families out there
struggling with this in all these
different ways well let's take again a
step back just a few years ago we
challenged ourselves with a bold 10-year
Mental Health Plan and it was bold it
was stakeholder driven we didn't have
bureaucrats write it we went out and
talked to the families we talked to the
students we talked to the kids we found
out where the system had been failing
them and then challenged ourselves to go
after a lot of those barriers and this
legislature has been aggressive and
taking on all those recommendations now
we kept that momentum going just last
summer the Department of Health and
Human Services launched what we call
Mission zero building on years of
progress with the goal of eliminating
emergency department boarding once in
for all and we're backing that mission
up with historic Investments you a lot
of you have seen this out there New
Hampshire has financed a public private
partnership with Solutions health for a
brand new state-of-the-art mental health
hospital we purchased Hamstead hospital
for children with acute mental illness
we are in the process of and almost done
reconstructing the wing the new Wings
over at New Hampshire hospital uh that
will add new beds slated to open in just
a couple months and we're building the
brand new forensic Hospital slated to
open next year all huge capital in
Investments with the goal of getting
citizens out of emergency rooms and into
the best care facilities possible and
our community Investments so critical
the best care is always in the community
when you can do it they are having
tremendous success as well last year
over 5,000 children were served through
the rapid response crisis Services over
2,000 received assistance from our
mobile response teams we've increased
mental health supported housing by 61%
we have a new crisis stabilization
centers moving patient away from the
emergency rooms those are opening up and
when it comes to Youth detention New
Hampshire now has the lowest rate in the
country so there's a lot of work ahead
of us but these transformational changes
have opened doors like never before and
given families choices when their kids
need it the most and remember if you're
out there and you're watching uh if
you're are a family or an individual in
crisis we remind ourselves all the time
you can always call 211 at any time to
be connected to an expert uh uh with
caring technical expertise for help and
assistance and unfortunately too often
our mental health efforts become become
tied in to the opioid and Fentanyl
crisis it continues to affect every
Community not only in New Hampshire but
really across the country now thanks to
our very successful doorway program that
we implemented back in 2019 New
Hampshire citizens have access to
wraparound services and options of care
across the state the New Hampshire we in
New Hampshire we created our recovery
friendly workplace program which has now
gone National we we're all very proud of
that allowing nearly a 100,000 citizens
right here in New Hampshire to now work
for a recovery friendly workplace New
Hampshire is now B bucking the
unfortunate National trend of
skyrocketing overdose deaths if you've
seen some of the data that is coming out
as we close out 23 the rest of the
country since 2018 the rest of the
country is up almost 60% in overdose
drug desks since 2018 our numbers have
actually gone down we've had a lot of
success there but that is no Solace no
Solace to the approximately 400 plus
families that will lose a loved one
right here in New Hampshire 400 families
are going to lose someone to that drug
crisis likely in the coming year so we
know that more always has to be done and
we know where it's coming from the
fentanyl Supply over America's Southern
border is increasing daily over the past
few years records amount of fentanyl
being smuggled into our system millions
of illegal migrants not just involved
with the human trafficking and the
extortion but with the deadly drug
trafficking that is killing New
Hampshire citizens now last year we had
about just just shy of 200 of our brave
men and women in our National Guard
those soldiers successfully assisted on
the southern border down in McKellen
Texas they just came back just a couple
months ago and we thank them for their
service and their duty to the country
tomorrow I will go to the legislature
and request funds for additional
National Guard to join other states
across the country down to Eagle Pass
Texas where some of the highest
incidents of illegal Crossings and drug
smuggling have occurred this is not a
Texas problem this is a national crisis
and New Hampshire has the chance to
provide specialized support follow the
laws of the land and keep our citizens
safe let's do
this and when we talk about brought our
brave men and women in service to our
country let's not forget the great work
New Hampshire is doing to help our
veterans I my goal is always been to be
the number one state for veteran
services and I thank the legislature for
their efforts creating our new first
ofit kind New Hampshire military
veterans campus which is currently under
construction up in Franklin New
Hampshire uh it it's under construction
today and will be accepting its first
veterans in 2025 whether it be
homelessness recovery mental Mental
Health Services led by more borgard and
her great team over at Easter Seals it
is going to be a gold standard for
veterans
care I won't be Governor but you got to
invite me to that ribbon cutting I just
want to see the place up and running
it's going to be great so look there's
no doubt about it times in New Hampshire
are good good management fiscal prudence
and a limited government worldview guide
our decision-making over these last
seven years New Hampshire has stood out
as a beacon of success and a safe haven
for freedom and
opportunity we have all put in the hard
work and this is what a true this has
always been a true team effort we fought
for lower taxes and it worked we fought
for more efficient government and it
worked we fought for local control and
decentralized government it worked we
fought for the rights of the individual
putting them before government and it
worked when we had one-time funds come
in instead of growing government or
instituting massive new programs we
focused on one-time projects instead of
a governing with a one-size fits-all
approach out of conquered we engage
stakeholders we engage those local
officials and those families shifting
decision-making in government to those
constituents on the front lines so if I
have one message to leave for this
legislature it is this you cannot to
take our amazing success for granted
fiscal Prudence definitely rules the day
understand that for the average citizen
out there personal debt it is at an
alltime high inflation has skyrocketed
across cost across to Everyday Americans
by over 20% in just a few years many New
Hampshire families are struggling
because of the just something as simple
as high prices at the grocery store and
these challenges are ofered beyond our
control so now more than ever it's more
important that we continue to minimize
the state's burden on taxpayers ensure
that the services we provide focus on
serving that individual and not just the
system responsible management of
taxpayer dollars will be of the utmost
importance if a recession hits and I'm
still a little concerned a recession
across this country very much could hit
it is our job as Leaders to make sure
that we're the last state to hit into
the recession and the first state to get
out but that requires restraint we are
strategic in New Hampshire we plan we
don't believe in just that okay
government's going to get it done we do
empow Empower that private sector to be
partners in our
success next year there'll be a new
governor and a new legislature and new
challenges to address oh we got a cheer
for that
one that was
funny but look we are so much better off
when we are working together and it's up
to each of you that return next year to
bring that same level of energy
cooperativeness and bipartisanship that
has helped us achieve so much together
New Hampshire truly has set a gold
standard now I'm not going in any
anywhere any anywhere anytime soon don't
get too excited you can keep the cheers
for another 10 months so let's keep
working hard let's keep doing it as a
team we can have our differences and the
political divide that's okay but at the
end of the day we have a great record
over these past few years of really
outshining the rest of the country
working together finding Solutions and
getting stuff done I just want to thank
all of you God bless you God bless the
great state of New Hampshire I
appreciate it guys thank
[Music]
you
I get my
[Music]
stuff
The Joint representative Osborne and
Senator Carson move that the joint
convention Ares are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
joint convention is
adjourned how long a day do you have
shouldn't be too bad yeah hear you're
still going
crazy
e
don't Don't Stray too far from your
seats we're just going to pull the
chairs out for the right now and and
then we'll uh get going uh with our
regular consent
calendar
e
we
for
members need to turn on their stations
as well Mr the the house will come to
order members need to turn your voting
stations
on the house will now attend to the send
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on legislative Administration House Bill
1152 removed by Representatives McLean
Shapiro wheeler James Murphy sherli
lelis Simpson PR gagy and
priest are there any other bills to be
removed pres Rosman moves at the consent
calendar with the relevant amendments as
printed in today's house record be
adopted are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose nay
the eyes haven't consent calendar is
adopted under rules of the house the
committee on education House Bill 1655
is referred the committee on Ways and
Means House Bill 1678 FN is referred to
the committee on finance committee on
executive departments and administration
hb1 1410 FN for the committee on Ways
and Means and the committee on
legislative Administration House Bill
1666 FN is referred the committee on
finance house will all tend the bills on
the regular
calendar majority of committee on
education to which was refer House Bill
1212 FN local enact relative eligibility
for free School meals having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
sen Mariel hall for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate sentive Mike
beler for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
beler thank you Mr Speaker and good
afternoon
colleagues I rise today against the
ought to pass motion on this bill this
bill would increase the free launch
program
from 180% of federal poverty level to
350% of federal poverty level and it
does so um with 100% New Hampshire
taxpayer funds with no hope for any
amount of reimbursement from the federal
government for
this the language within the bill itself
is slightly unclear as to whether one or
two meals would be required per day
resulting in competing fiscal analyses
of this
bill that put the final cost anywhere
from 50 million per year to perhaps 100
million per year or
higher currently not all schools even
opt into this program so the very Act of
passing this legislation and requiring
them to do so would represent an
unfunded mandate on these schools
requiring them to build facilities that
they don't already
have and as I said this is pure New
Hampshire taxpayer money yet it expands
a federal program now what that means is
we have zero ability to direct exactly
where we want these funds to go because
all federal USDA program mandates still
apply to this money even though it's New
Hampshire
money the USDA program has been
demonstrated out of a study in Boston to
be very wasteful 30% 30% waste product
from this program they attribute that
per studies to the inherent UNP
palatability of the foods because they
don't emphasize quality in this program
the nutrition guidelines themselves are
very controversial they're very old
guidelines they are very carbohydrate
heavy
guidelines
finally we heard numbers regarding food
insecurity we did not hear numbers on
food insufficiency and let me tell you
the difference they wanted to emphasize
to us the numbers of food Security in
the state are very high the definition
for food insecurity is I don't have
enough of the specific food that I want
to eat how does a child answer that
question the N food insecurity I'm sorry
insufficiency on the other hand is
actually the number of students who
don't have enough food period they would
not give us those
numbers we would like to see them before
we expend this kind of money and I would
ask for to Vision thank
you chair recognize representative
Hall thank you Mr Speaker and good
afternoon honorable
colleagues Mr Speaker today I rise in
support of house build
122 which increases the eligibility for
free School
meals this bill is similar to last
year's House Bill
572 which passed this body on a 2011 to
177 bipartisan
vote the intent of this bill is
twofold one to support a wider range of
low to Middle inome families by raising
the eligibility cap for free School
meals to
350% of the federal poverty level and
two to fund the cost of providing these
free School meals through the ex
existing Federal reimbursement program
combined with a new state reimbursement
program to be financed through the
education trust fund it does not affect
adequacy
grants School meals play a critical role
in a student's attendance well-being and
academic
success a healthy diet can give the
child the energy to think work and play
kids access to school meals has been
curtailed at a time when many families
continue to struggle with the rising
cost of putting food on the table this
bill ensures that our most needy
Children and adolescents receive at
least one nutritious meal per
day hunger that's really what this bill
is about childhood hunger over half of
New Hampshire children reportedly live
in households with insufficient food
imagine that some child's reality is
they don't know when their next meal
will be we're asking kids to be their
best selves under the worst of
circumstances we can do better than this
and we must do better than this this
bill is a positive step toward ending
childhood hunger in New
Hampshire School meals are as essential
as buses books computers internet access
let's do our part to ensure that New
Hampshire kids have food in their
bellies at least during their school day
a former superintendent testified that
the toughest part of his job was having
to make the decision to cancel school
knowing that some kids would not get a
meal that day House Bill 1212 is our
opportunity to commit to assisting
Granite State families in reducing food
insecurity our neighboring states of
Vermont Maine and Massachusetts all have
passed permanent Universal meals
legislation which this bill is not but
on that note I'd like to share a social
media post I saw last night while I Was
preparing for this floor
speech it was posted by my alamada the
gron school district and it said all
lunch bills at gron elementary school
have been paid off thanks to the
incredible generosity of an anonymous
donor this act of kindness Has Lifted a
significant burden off the shoulders of
many families in our community ensuring
that every child can enjoy nutritious
meals without any Financial worry
especially now that all students will
eat free going forward in that
Community I would like to think that the
majority of us have a similar priority
feeding kids is an investment in New
Hampshire's future it's not only the
right thing to do it's the least we can
do please join me in pressing the green
button so that we too can help feed
those kids who need it most thank you Mr
Speaker and I would like to request a
roll call
vote represent Hall has requested a roll
call vote is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your
seats please turn on your voting
stations
e
excis the motion before us a majority
commit a report of Auto pass on House
Bill
1212 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair as representative lad for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr
Speaker if I know 38 schools do not
currently participate in the national
school lunch or breakfast programs that
this state mandate requiring their
participation is made without
consideration for local control
decisionmaking and if I also know the
Bill's fiscal note estimate Ates the
total cost of the program to be more
than $50 million and potentially cost up
to $75 million with all funds coming
from the education trust fund regardless
of other high priority needs and if I
understand the bill not only disre
disregards local decision making but
will also have a significant financial
impact on the education trust fund would
I then press the red button so another
motion can be brought forward thank
you chair recognize renter Woodcock for
a parliamentary
inquiry afternoon thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that today everyone
sitting in this room had the opportunity
to attend a free breakfast or lunch and
had the ability to pay for it but didn't
have to and if I know the thousands of
New Hampshire students from needy
families did not or will not have either
a breakfast or a lunch today free or
otherwise and if I know that many of us
along the way had a hard Scrabble life
but we had a hand up along the way if I
know that I consistently hear from many
sitting here that education is all about
the kids well perhaps this is time to
support the kids and if I know that
fundament found foundationally the needs
of all people and children particularly
are two housing and food without which
students arriving at the schoolhouse
door missing those basic building blocks
will only reach a limited academic
potential and finally if I know that
last year when this bill passed
overwhelmingly in this house and again
on the other side and unanimously out of
committee I still can hear the words of
honorable art Ellison as he did his pi
and he said this bill is about one thing
feeding hungry kids it's not Republican
it's not Democrat it's simply about
feeding New Hampshire's hungry kids and
I ask you press the green button and do
just that thank you Mr Speaker the
motion before us a majority committee
report of autop pass on House Bill 1212
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
for
representative
marter representative
mcarter have all members had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
state of the
vote 187 voting yay 188 voting nay the
committee report fails for what reason
does a member rise to make a motion
State your motion I move inexpedient to
legislate it itl okay the motion before
us now is inexpedient to legislate on
how on on House Bill
1212 I see that the roll call is
sufficiently seconded I who yelled out
first okay got
it
so the motion before us now is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
the motion will be for inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1212 this is
going to be a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
represent
Peterson representative
fedus representative
fedus all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will agenda
state of the
vote 188 voting yay 187 voting
nay motion of inexpedient to legislate
passes without recommendation cordelli
moves on to pass and offers Amendment
0391 there's no debate on that one Boyd
is going to offer his Amendment CI
speak
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1419 FN relative to
prohibiting obscene or handful sexual
materials in schools this come to us
without
recommendation sen cordelli moves ought
to pass in office floor Amendment
0391 H printed in house record 6 page 34
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I
those oppos
[Applause]
nay a division has been
called members take your
seats the house will be in
order
this will be a division vote for
confirmation
only this is on Amendment 0391
h if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds in the voting mode we're in the
voting
mode
[Music]
represent
love represent
Lees
Kelly
St
boy if all members president had an
opportunity to vote I'll will attend to
stay to the
vote 100 185 voting a 188 voting a the
amendment
fails fur am on second reading open to
further Amendment representative Boyd
offers floor Amendment
070 representative cordelli is going to
speak against it representative
cordelli uh thank you Mr Speaker uh this
amendment basically replaces the bill
um it has been said that a law without
enforcement is just a
suggestion this amendment makes this
bill a
suggestion it turns its back on parents
parents who have found inappropriate
materials age inappropriate educational
materials in their schools and want
redress it removes the ability for the
State Board of Education to be in a
part of the appeal process for a parent
and one of the duties of the State Board
of Education is to hear appeals from
parents when there are dispute there is
a dispute with their local uh
District we cannot um ignore the age
inappropriate materials some of which I
understand some people passed out today
um
outside parents are paying attention to
to what we do here
today we need to have the appeals
process and the enforcement mechanisms
in place that were worked out with the
Attorney General's office we can't gut
this bill I ask you to vote red on this
floor Amendment if this floor Amendment
passes I'll vote against my own
bill
chair recognize representative
Boyd thank thank you Mr Speaker and
through you to my esteemed colleagues of
the New Hampshire General Court my floor
Amendment provides an alternative
approach to tackling OB City within our
public schools first it's enabling
school districts have the choice to opt
in or not lastly it's a standardized
four-prong approach and appeals process
for grieved parents to pursue beginning
with the school principal to the
assistant superintendent to the school
superintendent and ultimately ending
with the local school board being the
final Arbiter of the
appeal keeping these decisions at the
local level holds local decision makers
accountable for their actions on
questions of obscenity placing these
decisions with an unelected bureaucratic
State Board of Education would
politicize decision-making with no
accountability to these decision makers
as well creating a local process for
school districts to fall on questions of
obscenity provides a sensible solution
to addressing a societal challenge that
is impacting today's youth please join
by pressing the green button to move
this amendment forward and Mr Speaker
I'd ask for a division vote thank
you the motion before is a boy boy floor
Amendment
070 he's asked for a a division vote
members take your seats who requests a
roll call true true requests a roll call
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
for
C the motion before us is the boid floor
Amendment
070 it is in your seat Pockets this is
going to be a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent
Jones representes
thankes all m president an opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 17 voting
a 358 voting aay the floor Amendment
fails we are back to ought to
pass on houseal Bill
1419 chair recognizes representative
cordelli thank you Mr Speaker
the opponents of this bill will tell you
that this bill is about banning books
that's
false it is about our sexualized K12
education it is about materials in our
schools that are harmful to M to
minors it is about age inappropriate
educational
materials educational
materials this bill is the result of
working for hours with our attorney
general and his
staff a recent Rasmus poll found that
69% of Voters Believe Books containing
explicit sexual depictions of sex acts
should not be presidents Public
Schools the majority opposed sexually
explicit books Rose to 79% for middle
schools and 85% for elementary schools
currently our state criminal statutes on
obscenity exempt
education you heard that correctly
education is
exempt this bill removes K12 education
from that ex
exemption but it is doubtful that any
criminal charges will ever be brought uh
in relation to K12 education
charges this bill also establish a
minimum process a minimum process by
which parent parents can bring in
appropriate materials to the attention
of their principal and their school
board if that uh complaint is not heard
and addressed they can appeal that to
the State Board of
Education it is a process that is
already in statute under the duty of the
State Board of Education to hear the
complaints of parents if they have a
complaint against their local school
board this bill would also provide civil
action by a parent under two conditions
one the district did not follow the
complaint process or two there was a
determination that the material should
be moved or removed but the school did
not act on it under only those two
circumstances is there a civil
process and what materials are we
talking about we are talking about
possibly sexually explicit materials
books about suicide about cutting
yourself with people people talking
about the Mental Health crisis in our
schools is this what we want available
to our
children we are talking about books but
also a common applic a on many school
computers that describe things such as
incest with a daughter who becomes a
prostitute sex between adults including
teachers and minor girls getting raped
and drug use and
violence let me read you some
excerpts for anyone watching at home
I'll pause for a second so you can turn
down the volume if you
wish I'll read just two
exerpts
first
but is there I I'm not sure what you're
going to say but if it's graphic in any
way you can't say
it I'll be in
order but just think about it for a
second apparently straight Cy people
lose their virginity when a penis goes
into a vagina so what happens if a penis
isn't
involved the
rep the the rep the representative will
please keep
it in the proper
perspective this is this is from
Material in a middle
school I open my mouth to breathe to
scream and his hand covers it in my head
my voice is as clear as a bell no I
don't want to but I can't spit it out
I'm trying to remember how we got on the
ground and where the moon went and Wham
shirt up shorts down the ground smells
wet and dark and no I'm not really here
rep repres representative
Celli
I'm asking you to keep
it civil without getting into graphic
all
right I know this is a very sensitive
situation for both
sides I am trying to make sure that
nothing too bad gets spoken at the the
same
time the member has a right to
speak so let's all keep it in proper
perspective if I feel any member is
going too far I will speak to them but
every member has a right to
speak uh thank you Mr Speaker I'll
continue with this uh passage from a
book in a middle
school I'm not really here I'm
definitely back at Rachel's house
crimping my hair and gluing on my fake
fingernails he smells like beer and he's
mean and he hurts me he hurts me he
hurts me and gets up zips up his pants
and
smiles are these educational
materials thank
you
people
this stop everybody stop it
now
the house will be in order the member
has a right to speak I've corrected them
twice and I will correct them again if I
have to point of order speak your point
of order speak your point of
order Mr Speaker do we not have a rule
that says that when a member objects to
the reading from a paper that the member
must suspend unless the house votes to
let them cons
continue yes we
do I object to the reading of the
material that the gentleman is
reading Mr
Speaker we will now vote on we will now
vote on whether the member can s
continue a roll call has been requested
it is sufficiently
seconded
I
The House of the house be an order
member take your seats we are in the
voting
mode the motion before us is
whether representative cordelli can
continue
speaking this is going to be a roll call
vote it's a simple
majority chair recognizes representative
Weber for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker
speaker if I know that we all understand
the point that the member was trying to
make and if we know that the way in
which he was making it was offensive to
many and triggering to some that are
victims of violence or abuse would I now
vote green uh I'm sorry I need to ask I
now need to ask which way Mr Speaker
could you restate the question for me
because I'm was it notwithstanding or
was
it member continue voting I mean would I
now and this is why we do parliamentary
inquiries press red on the
question chair recognize representative
Sweeney for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
offensive material is already available
to countless New Hampshire Public School
students would I not vote green now to
allow the member to continue and
Enlighten the House of Representatives
as to what material is available thank
you the motion before us is shall the
member continue speaking this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're appros
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
to
all the members president had an
opportunity to vote household tend to
stay to the
vote
201 201 voed y 173 voting nay the member
may
continue will be in order
well for what reason is a member rise I
uh M to make a motion sir he's in the
middle of his spe he's in the middle of
his speech right
now I'm actually a little bit past the
middle but that's all
right materials like I just
read are available in many schools
including Bedford High School do middle
school and high school exitor schools
and many schools including the governor
Wentworth School District on the sore
app we need to focus on academic
achievement and
knowledge the state average for English
language arts in the fifth grade is just
over 50% for math it's below
40% let's be
honest these explicit sexual and age
inap apprpriate materials have no place
in our
schools and I repeat this is not about
banning books is making sure that your
children have access to age appropriate
educational materials
period is the member yield of
questions yes member yields s bville you
may
inquire oh
sorry thank you Mr Speaker and and thank
you for taking the
question do you find
it acceptable that we have materials
available to minor children in public
schools in New
Hampshire that many take offense to as
being read aloud on the floor of the New
Hampshire House of
Representatives
I think many people will find it quite
enlightening member you a to further
questions yes sen of love you may
inquire thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues uh thank you representative
uh would it be safe to say that uh that
vulgarity and profanity in public
schools uh could be a driving force
between behind the the education Freedom
accounts I'm not going to um uh pretend
to uh uh know what U drives parents to
uh have their children take education
Freedom accounts but certainly uh there
are many education Freedom account
parents that are concerned about uh the
education in their current school and
choose to uh pursue other
options so member you to further
questions motion May
inquire thank you for taking my question
question my question is if material is
inappropriate to read on the house floor
wouldn't that automatically make it
inappropriate to present to K through 12
students um if you're asking for a vote
on that I'll vote say uh vote Yes will
the member yield to further questions
yes member May
inquire thank you for taking my question
do we know the impact of harmful
materials on our children
um yeah actually I think that there are
a couple of um indications there was um
a recent uh youth risk behavior survey
and I believe the um some of the results
in there uh could be impacted by these
materials um one of the questions was
the percent of females ever physically
forced to the sex to sex intercourse
when they did not not want to in my area
it was 19% and Statewide it was
14% second question females who have
experienced sexual violence during the
past year in my area it was 21% and in
the state almost
18% there was also a recent CDC report
that said that between 2017 and 21 teen
girl girls who experience sexual
violence increased by
20% I think that uh perhaps there are a
number of factors but could materials
such as the be one of them I think so is
a member yeld to further questions yes
remember
Els uh thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for taking my question in the caca I
I I may have lost it but in the words uh
you were reading I I did you did you
also mean to mention the images that are
available since a picture is worth a
thousand words I understand that there
are some very graphic images of of uh
sexual performance in these books as
well is that true or
not uh yes it is and uh uh on a number
of occasions some of those images were
passed around in our education committee
and we had members of our committee who
refused to look at them so you know I uh
don't know what happens in schools but
uh if our own members won't look at the
images uh I fear for our children so
member yield to further question
yes you may inquire all right I thank
the member for taking a question this is
maybe a more specific question that he
can answer but in the case of um
teaching kids foreign languages um
particular I'm thinking of Latin um do
we are you do you support them being
taught to count um above five because I
believe any of us who stud in Latin know
what the number Latin word for six is so
do you
support uh only limiting Latin
instruction when they teach them about
numbers to zero through five or
not uh I'm sorry I don't know
Latin does a member yeld a further
question yes member
yields thank you for taking my
question are you aware in any of these
books that these ebooks that are
available are there hyperlinks to sex
dating sex apps such as Match.com and
are there instructions on how to upload
pictures um and meet with people who
have um similar
thoughts I have not tried any such links
but I heard that they are available is a
member yield to further
questions yes or no no member does not
yield chair recognizes representative
Tanner Mr speaker now can I Rise for a
motion yes State your motion all right I
move to table this thank you I'm sorry
table oh move the table the motion is a
proper motion the motion before is
the is the
table it is sufficiently seconded
I
that's
clear
in
seat their
seat
the motion before us is to table hell
Bill
1419 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Myer for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I believe that this is an
extreme and controversial
bill and if I believe that this bill
will ban books and censor material and
the availability of controversial
material if I believe that an individual
parent has a right to select books and
material
that are appropriate for their
children but not but they cannot have
that right to make for all
parents if I believe that professional
teachers and Librarians and others
should not be subject to arrest
discipline loss of professional license
just because they are providing material
they feel that is important for students
to create critical
thinkers and if I believe that this it's
the duty of local elected school boards
to create the community literacy
standard that should be available to
students and not have that local
judgment challenged and adjudicated by
the State Board of
Education and finally Mr Speaker if I
know that a bipartisan Bill HB
1311 will be soon coming before this
body and that IT addresses this very
topic
in a constructive and bipartisan fashion
would I now press the green button to
table House Bill
1419 thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Sweeney for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know I
want to start by welcoming everyone back
to the chamber and if I further know
that we seem to agree that this
underlying material is offensive uh and
may not belong in this house chamber uh
and would I further know that that same
material doesn't belong in our schools
would I then press the red button so
that the underlying motion can be passed
thank
you the motion before us is the table
House Bill 1419 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
repr
[Music]
Shapiro
represent
Granger while members present had an
opportunity to vote househ attend to
stay to the
vote 192 voting yay 181 voting nay house
bill 14 one n's laid on the
table what reason does the member rise
to make a motion State your motion to
print the remarks from the previous
debate in the permanent
Journal
iest did we hear roll call requests yes
represent partial is requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded is it
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote
[Music]
e
motion before us is to print the remarks
on House Bill 1419 in the permanent
Journal it's going to be a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're post you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
represent
re and representative S I need a vote
thank
you okay all members president had an
opportunity to vote El will attend to
stay the
vote 291 voting a 84 voting
a it will be
printed committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 1524 relative to
authorizing parents of special education
children to observe in the classroom
setting this comes to us without
recommendation in a dry moves ought to
pass chair recogniz repr
cascaden
yeah thank you Mr Speaker I promise to
tell the truth the whole truth nothing
but the truth so help me
God house bill
1524 is proposing that school boards add
a policy allowing parents of students
identified in special education to
observe their child in the classroom
setting a parent's right to observe his
or her child during the school day is
supported by federal
law family education rights and Privacy
Act known as furpa does not prohibit a
parent of a child with disabilities from
observing uh the parent child in the
classroom however the the US Department
of Ed office of special education and
rehabilitation services known as
oep has the following guidance while
idea expects parents of children with
disabilities to have an expanded role in
developing reviewing and revising the
individualized education plans of their
children neither the statute nor the
regulations implementing
idea Grant an entitlement for parents of
children with disab abilities or their
professional representatives to observe
their children in any current classroom
or proposed educational
placement local school districts have
policies and procedures that address
School visitors and do do provide
opportunities for parents to observe
their child in the classroom setting if
they are identified in need of special
education services House Bill 1524 does
not provide provide new policy that
doesn't already exist in special
education procedural safeguards I urge
my bipartisan colleagues to vote no on
OTP so that another motion can be made
to itl House Bill
1524 thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
dry
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues parents of special education
students have by Design more involvement
in their child's education plan than
most parents do they have to deal with
plans permissions personnel and
paperwork that others do not as a vital
part of their child's IEP team parents
should have reasonable opportunities to
observe their child's classroom or
proposed placement options this bill
requires school districts to develop
policies allowing classroom
observation but isn't that opportunity
already available apparently not
everywhere because this bill comes at
the request of a constituent of the
sponsor during our hearings some object
objected to the phrase inside the bill
that reads school districts shall impose
no conditions or restrictions on such
observations and I agree that that
sounds overly
permissive but it has to be read in
conjunction with the rest of the
sentence that says except those
necessary to ensure the safety of the
children in the program to ensure the
Integrity of the program while under
observation and to protect the
confidentiality of those involved in the
program this bill recognizes the
important role that parents play in
special education and allows a parent to
observe a program while still guarding
the Integrity the safety and the
confidentiality of the program I hope
you will support extending this
opportunity to all special education
parents in the state and vote HB 1524
ought to
pass the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1
524 are you ready for the
question
all a division has been requested
members take your
seats
than
the motion before us is ought to pass an
House Bill 1524 this is a division vote
chair recognize representative B bony
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that federal law
mandates that schools actively involve
parents of students with disabilities in
the development and evaluation of their
CH child's educational goals including
classroom
observations and I know that public
school districts already have policies
and procedures in place to to provide
reasonable opportunities to observe in
the
classroom further if I know that all
students including those with special
needs can be sensitive to changes in the
classroom
routine so teachers should be allowed
flexibility in accommodating visitors
while respecting all students individual
educational needs and
privacy then would I now press the red
button to keep classroom access
decisions at the local level and allow
another motion to be made thank you do
you recognize representative Celli for
parliamentary inquiry uh thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I'd like to read
some material oh I'm sorry wrong Pi um
Mr Speaker if I know that HB
1525 simply requires a district policy
to allow parents to observe their
special needs child in the
classroom if I know that observations
can be restricted by the school to
ensure safety program integrity and
ensure the privacy of other children in
the
classroom and if I know that this just
follows the goals of most districts to
increase parental engagement and promote
transparency would I now press the green
button the motion before us is aut to
pass on House Bill 524 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote how attend to stay to the vote
187 voting a 185 voting a the committee
report is adopted got to
pass committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1652 FN relative to
establishing a local education Freedom
account
program presentative cord moves ought to
pass chair
recognizes chair recognizes
representative
Damon thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon colleagues House Bill 1652
enables school districts to create a
local taxpayer funded EFA program it
would require require increased property
taxes to pay for Education outside of
local public schools students would be
eligible regardless of the family income
or capacity to pay make no mistake this
is not a cost-saving measure for local
school districts but rather it is a
subsidy for private and religious
education for students of wealthy
families and unlike the current EFA
program the costs would be borne
entirely by local
taxpayers as with the existing EFA
program there is no accountability for
expenditures there are no academic
standards for services or materials paid
for through the program there are no
background checks to assure safety of
the children there are no assessments to
evaluate the outcomes and there is not
even any data collected as to whether
students received any educational
services at all according to the
Department of Education most students
receiving state efas were not attending
Public Schools when they entered the
program we should expect the same if
local efas are created public Community
School costs will not go
down further there is great risk that a
small contingent of people motivated to
dismantle Public Schools could vote to
create local efas in small communities
where School meting ings often lack
substantial voter participation I'm from
cin I know what that looks like the bill
states that if a community starts a
local EFA even if they later resend the
program the students already enrolled
must be covered until High School
graduation this is an unfunded mandate
which we all know is against statute you
cannot bind the community to pay for
Education grants for 12 years ahead
as representatives of and for our
communities we are obligated to practice
fiscal
responsibility we are all hearing from
our constituents who are distressed by
increased local property taxes
especially in the context of Greater
living expenses yet this bill would pay
out twice the amount of the state based
adequacy plus any differentiated Aid to
which the student qualifies there is no
family income cap so any student will
qualify please join me in the fiscally
responsible vote of opposing OTP so a
better motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
vervo thank you Mr Speaker this is
enabling
legislation this legislation just like
the current law to allow a local
community to go from traditional town
meeting to to the sb2 form of town
meeting or back to traditional town
meeting it's the same mechanism it
requires a 60% vote of the local school
district to enable this legislation so
it's hard to imagine that some small
cabal looking to dismantle public
education in New Hampshire and some
Community is going to get 60% of the
vote this is this is the vote of the
people living in in their own District
to to have their their voice heard for
their own self-determination to decide
if they want some some of the local uh
education Monies to be able to to follow
the
child it's easy ballot access requires
25 signatures of registered voters from
the community so it's it's easy
access the question to enable and the
question to disable the program in a
district is defined in the
RSA so there wouldn't be any playing of
games with how the question is worded it
shall we shall we vote to approve or
shall we vote to
discontinue let's just pretend for a
second that your school district enables
this what's the uptake
rate I think we all have to admit that's
the great un
known I can only speak for my own
Community because that's that's where I
have the intimate
connection and if Deerfield enabled this
program my gut tells me the uptake rate
would be very
low most people want their children to
attend their local public school they
want their children to be raised with
that sense of community that sense of of
neighborhood so that they grow up with
the kids around around them and they
have a sense of place as they grow up I
think we all agree with
that your local public school is
obligated by state law prek through 8 to
provide free transportation to and from
school for most families that's a huge
carrot it's a huge carrot so if your
community enables this program if this
when this bill
passes then anybody that avails thems of
this program they they have to provide
their own transportation so it's it's
it's not a free
lunch the the only districts that would
have to to be a little bit nervous if
this was
enabled is if they have what the people
in the district would deem a failing
public school it's not my opinion my
opinion on the quality of their public
schools has no bearing on this right
it's it's the local community and if a
school district enables this and all of
a sudden kids are fleeing their local
District doesn't that tell the Local
District isn't that a positive feedback
loop that they are not providing the
goods and services that the children and
the families of that District want and
that is that is a feedback loop to
improve public
education we hear about private schools
and parochial
schools well there's nothing that would
stop a family from taking this EFA Grant
and applying it to another public school
you know it you know it's state law that
local public schools can tuition in
students from other districts if they if
they so choose right and so most school
districts in this state uh have a long
run decades run of declining student
population so so maybe this would be a
good way for schools to attract more
students to buoy their local public
school system right it's not all doom
and gloom let's let's not let's not say
that yeah it's it's double State
adequacy it's double state adequacy in
this bill if you enable it a child that
takes a local EFA is counted towards the
average daily attendance that I'm sorry
average daily membership of the school
so they are still considered a member of
that local public school district so the
state adequacy flows to the district and
then flows to the child flows to the
student and then the Local District only
has to m that amount the vast majority
of our school
districts spend more than twice State
adequacy on to educate students today in
their districts that means that there is
a a reserve of Revenue that still stays
in the local school you know it's funny
right when when somebody says a kid's
going to leave a public school is 100%
fixed cost oh my God if a kid leaves the
funding unit goes and and we can't we
can't make ends meet but yet when a kid
shows is up it's all variable cost well
we didn't plan for that extra kid it's
going to cost all this extra money well
it can't be both ways and it's not both
ways it's in the middle and honestly it
depends on the school district it
depends on the the finances of the
school district and this bill allows the
local uh citizens of the school district
to make this decision for them yeah yeah
if you enable it and a kid participates
they're grandfathered in you have to
have a safety net for families
so you're going to enable this as a
program runs for a year two years 5
years 10 years and it gets disabled for
whatever reason right whatever the
community decides well we don't want
shifting Sands under our students right
we all agree we want a measure of
consistency in in children's education
and so this is a safety net for families
that in good faith choose to participate
if if if a school district choos
uh to make this make this
possible surprised we haven't we haven't
heard cries about special
ed another beauty of this
bill is that if the student qualifies
for special ed
services it grants unilateral authority
to the local school district to decide
where and when specialed services will
be delivered so in other words if
Deerfield enabled this and I took my
child out of the public school and went
somewhere else I can't tell the local
school district by the way I want the
speech pathologist uh down at the new
school in Manchester on Tuesday at 9: I
can't do that the school district can
tell me the speech pathologist will be
available Tuesdays at 9: in the local
school right so it it adds fairness for
everybody and it doesn't change it
doesn't alter any of the special ed
costs think about that doesn't change
costs by enabling or not enabling this
this
legislation it's for rich
people we do not means test public
education in New
Hampshire when my children became of
school age and I brought them to the
Deerfield community school that's our
local public school they didn't say well
excuse me Mr veral how much do you make
a year well you qualify for English
mathematics and science um art music gym
history etc etc etc uh that's going to
be a little extra because you know
you're you're rich and we don't want to
subsidize the education of your children
public
education is paying for the education of
children of a community using public
dollars some people think that public
education is a public school they think
it's a building but it's not it's paying
for the education of our children using
public monies and this bill um stands
that stands that test the rich already
have
options State
FAS they go a long ways it's I don't
know where's where's representative 4500
a year State adequacy somewhere around
there right now right and that helps a
lot of families that otherwise couldn't
afford another option this doubles that
amount it doubles state adequacy that
puts a huge spectrum of educational
possibilities Within Reach of even the
most financially struggling families in
the state the rich can already afford to
send their kids to private school okay
it's the Working Poor it's the lower
middle class those are the people that
can't afford it and and if we if we say
adequacies $4,500 we're talking about
nine grand a year per student that is
more than enough to allow the V V
majority of families uh wide openen
educational opportunities that's a
win-win that's a win for taxpayers
that's a win for for parents that's a
win for students that's a that's a great
thing the other thing I'll I'll
say is we hear there's no accountability
fiscally right but there's no lawsuit
saying that there's fraud on State efas
and the local EFA follows the same
system so the system seems to be working
at the state level because there's no
court cases bringing it down with all
this fraud so that's an accusation
without any supporting evidence uh that
I'm aware of so let's not worry about
that and as for academic accountability
I was a little surprised by that perhaps
the the member of the education
committee chose not to read the
bill section 10 part three lowercase D
number three to provide an annual record
of Education
attainment by the students they will
take the Statewide student assessment
test any child that participates in a
local EFA if it's enabled takes the
Statewide assessment test imagine that
we'd finally get that data set they've
been asking for they want to they want
to know how are kids at private schools
religious schools other schools doing
this would give us that because kids
that part choose to participate have to
take the Statewide assessment we'd
finally get that data if for no other
reason I would vote for this bill just
to get that that set of
data this is a great bill it splits very
carefully responsibility and fairness to
school districts as well as to parents
and students as well as
taxpayers if it's a runaway fiscal train
it won't be but if it is then the
district disables it right it's that
simple it's it's not a small cabal of
Voters it's 60% of the voters at the
school
district so thank you and please vote
green on o pass thank
you the recommendation before us is
ought to pass on House Bill
1652 are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
take your
seats oh my mistake does a member yield
to a
question member does not
[Music]
yield
e
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill
1652 this is a division
vote chair recognized representative
luno for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr
Speaker if I know the EFA program isn't
about kids leaving Public Schools but
it's about the state using the state
budget to pay tuition costs for kids
already into private and religious
schools and are way over budget today
because of it and if I know local
property taxes should not have to open
up their checkbooks too to pay for these
private school tuition costs and that
property taxpayers shouldn't have to
face these challenges and petitions
every year then would I press the red
button to defeat this motion so that
another motion be could be made and put
this bill to rest thank
you here recognize representative lad
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this bill allows the
school district to establish a local
education Freedom account program for
eligible resident students and if I know
this enabling legislation requiring a
60% super majority vote of District
voters that can also be rescinded by a
similar action at any time and if I
believe Educational Opportunity provided
by local education Freedom accounts will
give parents the power to choose the
educational options that best fit their
children through public dollars
following the
child would I then press the green
button in support of local education
choice and this wonderful option that
will be available to local community
thank
you motion before us is ought to pass an
House Bill 1652 with this a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're oppos you'll
press a red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote household tend to stay the
vote 180 voting yay 192 voting nay the
autop pass motion
fails what reason if member rise uh to
make a motion Mr State your motion I
move itl and call division call the
motion before us
is in expedient to legislate a roll call
has been requested it is sufficiently
seconded members take your
seats
for
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate and House Bill 1652 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent MS
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote also attend to stay
to the
vote 194 voting a 179 voting a the
motion of inexpedient to legislate
passes
ch
the committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1677 FN relative to
participation in education Freedom
accounts based on school or School
District proficiency scores comes to us
without
recommendation representative cordelli
moves a to pass and offers Amendment
0389 H printed in house record 6 on page
37 the question is on the amendment are
you ready for the
question what now division all right
this will be a division vote members
take your
seats
e
I
just
the question is on the adoption of
amendment
0389 H and this is a division vote if
you're in favor of adopting the
amendment press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
evil I need a thumb representative thank
you represent
RS
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
121 in the affirmative 246 and the
negative the amendment
fails that leaves us with the motion of
ought to pass representative taner
recognized to speak against the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker HB
1677 is yet one more bill to expand the
educational Freedom accounts that give
money directly to parents to spend on
the education of their
children this program has the member
suspend for a moment
sure I can barely hear and I'm right
here if you want to have a conversation
that's what the Anor room is for
continue thank you this program has
little accountability financially or
academically this bill uses test scores
of public schools but not Charter
Schools as the basis for eligibility to
the program the EFA program was
originally promoted and designed for
lowincome families 1677 implies that
people will be taking their children out
of an underperforming public school yet
most of the struggling public schools
are located where families have lower
economic resources and higher numbers of
reduced and free lunch students these
are areas where F many families could
already apply based on income if they
wanted to there is no data to indicate
that children with education Freedom
accounts perform any better on
standardized assessments compared with
students in public schools in fact most
of those receiving vouchers are not
required to do or take the same
assessment as the public school students
75% of EFA students have never attended
public school and homeschooled students
are not required to take
assessments public school students take
a test for English language arts and
Mathematics in grades 38 and SATs in
grade 11 science is only measured in
grade 5 8 and 11 these are one-day tests
given that give a limited snapshot into
the ability and the achievement of
students these test scores are not a
true measure of the student or the
school's
success proficiency is a moving
Target in I was asked or I asked the
sponsor of this bill what proficiency
would mean in terms of you know old
school like when I went to school ABC D
and no one seems to know or what's the
standard just below proficiency is it
basic intermediate nobody seems to know
1677 allows a family who merely lives in
the geographic area of a school or
School District that has any low test
scores in any subject assessments that
are only given potentially three times
in a school students career those
students do not have to be in public
school or charter school or have an
income qualification to qualify for full
access to the
EA they simply need to reside in that
geographic area at that one moment of
time to get the yearly money for the
rest of their child's education from
kindergarten to age
22 without an income criteria the
families who have already chosen private
religious or homeschool options based
solely on concerns about academic scores
have already found a way to afford those
options but under this program they
would now be able to access taxpayer
resourced money to add to their
household income to offset the tuition
and homeschool materials costs they
already can afford the cost of this
program for the current year is
estimated at about $60 million money
coming from the educational trust fund
without a cap on this program's funding
who knows what state funds will be
needed uh to be raised in the future we
continually see bills like this that
imply that our New Hampshire schools are
failing you heard heard this morning
they're amazing and they're not failing
we know that 165,000 students and their
parents actively choose their
neighborhood Public Schools where
children go to school with their friends
and neighbors where they have
professionally licensed teachers who are
dedicated to Preparing children and
learning academics and meeting the
challenges of life for the future the
EFA program is using money that could be
used for our Public Schools in areas
like building aid for schools where
which are some a 100 years old money
that could be spent to lower the burden
of retirement fund cost to schools and
taxpayers money to give more services
resources and help to struggling schools
in low economic areas money for school
lunches and breakfasts for Hungry kids
Public Schools should be spent for the
public good for the cherishing of public
education as defined in our state
Constitution without an income
requirement the state will be
subsidizing those already in exclusive
private schools this new category opens
up an opportunity and will allow the
ultra wealthy in our state who do not
need the state's help to send their kids
to these schools while doing nothing for
our struggling neighborhood public
schools in places like Berlin Claremont
Franklin and elsewhere around the state
we need to get more accountability in
finan Financial guard rails expenditure
caps on EFA
program that on the EFA program that
already exists and support our Public
Schools before we accept these ideas on
how to expand
eligibility the result of all these
proposed eligibility categories is to
expand the education Freedom account to
a financially unchecked Universal
program that will become a very costly
State obligation and an equally costly
burden for the 165,000 public school
students their parents and the local
taxpayers I urge you to vote no on this
bill so another motion may be made thank
you Mr
Speaker representative H is recognized
to speak in support of the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker the bill before for us is known
as the every student learns
act L's education achievement in
reforming neglectful schools that might
be
harsh but if you look at what our
schools are doing in terms of
performance we're not delivering a
quality
education the the prior speaker
mentioned this is only about wealthy
towns they are delivering they're
delivering education
fine and it's only the the moderate low
inome towns that have
issues the find member from the corner
office um our distinguished Governor his
Excellency comes from the town of
newfields and I just looked it up and
only 40% of the students in that
town and I say that again 40% are
proficient in science that's just one of
many towns I could go through the entire
State town by
town I point out some of these in an
article this morning in the con sorry in
the union
leader I point out out the largest
District in the the largest school
district in the town or in the state is
the town of Manchester or the city of
Manchester and and every subject less
than one in three is performing
adequately or is proficient by the time
they
graduate how can we defend spending
taxpayer money for that level of quality
if one out of four students is getting
an education the other three aren't
we're handicapping those other three for
Life the education committee heard this
and they wanted to try and modify it a
little bit to see if they could get it
passed through that other body but this
body should determine the policy and if
the other body wants to pick it up
that's
great the bill has a fiscal note the
fiscal note at the time of printing of
the bill was UN right was undetermined
it is still undetermined in the latest
fiscal note I've seen online this will
be going in to the fiscal committee for
further analysis if passed out of this
chamber
this is not just about lowincome
districts in the
state there are those that but Hudson
isn't in that list Hudson isn't making
the grade when it comes to
performing this isn't about whether it's
a minority District or single- income
moms or single- income
dads this is about giving our children
the best possible
education so that they can SU succeed in
life in the
70s somebody thought whole language was
this great idea we should come up with a
new way to teach kids to read and
English they tried it in my local school
system it was great we could learn to
read really
fast unfortunately phonetics was not
part of the
solution so I got to learn phonetics
about how to sound out words when we
started teaching my
children English in my
30s guess what learning really big long
complicated words like you'd find in the
medical field became
hard because I couldn't break it down
into the constituent
Parts was easy in math because I learned
math
unfortunately that impacted my
livelihood and my career
choices our school system back then
could have done better I want the best
education for our children that's
possible and if the child is not getting
inadequate education meaning the
majority of the children are hitting
Proficiency in that District it is time
to give the parents an option
out we choose our education based on zip
code and date of birth that's how we
assign children to the
classroom that is the
least sorry that is the most inefficient
way to educate a child and to select a
classroom has nothing to do with
learning style are they an auditory
learner do they learn Hands-On are they
a visual
learner do they have great aptitude and
they should be ahead in a classroom no
we put them in a classroom and we assign
it by date of birth and zip code let's
do better than that this bill says if
you're not getting a good enough
education at your home District then you
can go elsewhere please pass this Bill
thank
you representative grer requests roll
calls ask sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your
seats
it's pretty fast
right
C
question before the house is the motion
of ought to pass on House Bill
1677 and this is a roll call vote
representative Cornell is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that according to the Department of
Education this wildly expensive bill
will result in an indeter Al number of
new students accessing the program
making it go over the amount set aside
in the budget for the program if I know
this bill expands eligibility to any
student whose enrollment transfer
request was denied with no income
threshold and to any student in a
district that scores the below the 49th
profession below 49% proficiency on
Statewide tests in any area whether they
attend a school in the district or not
and if I know that this bill which the
sponsor called the reforming negligent
schools act assumes that districts are
intentionally scoring poorly on
Statewide assessments to get more funds
as he said in our committee but not take
into account the high number of English
language learner students in Manchester
2,000 out of 12,000 students are English
language Learners and take the test our
homeless students in Manchester 800
students are
homeless remember will Supan you're
you're up here for parliamentary inquiry
not a speech that's part of
it um nope it isn't just a little bit
800 students are thinking about their
next meal
[Music]
representative I know I know no if I
know that there are 800 homeless
students in Manchester who are thinking
about their next meal not their score on
an assessment test and if I know this
makes eligibility Universal and that no
one knows what this could cost taxpayers
then would I press the red button so
another motion can be
made representative hols recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that our
kids deserve the best possible education
we can give them if I further know that
certain school districts in this state
aren't making that
happen if I know it's not about the
dollars it's about giving the kids the
best possible chance at their future
would I now vote green on ought to pass
thank
you the question before the house is a
motion about to pass on House Bill 16 77
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button if you're
opposed press the red voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the
vote 174 in the affirmative 192 in the
negative the motion
fails for what reason does it member us
Mr Speaker I'd like to move itl on this
motion and ask for a division vote
please
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 1677 and this is a
division vote you should all be here in
your seats but let's yell in the
hallways
anyway
the question is on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1677 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 192 in the affirmative 174 in the
negative the motion is
adopted for what reason does a member
ask Mr speak Mr Speaker having voted on
the prevailing side on house bills
1677 I would request a reconsideration
vote a division vote and and urge my
colleagues to vote no on the
reconsideration repres representative
Miler moves reconsideration on House
Bill 1677 and did you ask for a division
vote he did and he asked for a division
vote so this will be a division vote
members take your
seats maybe don't bail out of the
chamber 4 seconds after a
vote
the question is on reconsideration of
House Bill
1677 if this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 175 in the affirmative 193 in the
negative reconsideration
fails for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side on House Bill
1652 I would like to reconsider this and
urge the uh body to vote no on
reconsideration and I'd like a division
vote thank you Mr
Speaker representative Miler moves
reconsideration of House Bill
1652 and this will be a division vote
members take your
seats
the question is whether to reconsider
House Bill
1652 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 177 in the affir of 190 and the
negative reconsideration
fails for what reason does the member
rise for what reason does the member
rise okay thank you Mr Speaker members
of the house I wish to make a a motion
of reconsideration on House Bill 1212
and I wish to speak briefly to my
motion uh Mr Speaker I hang on a sec I'm
sorry okay thank you I goofed on my vote
on House member will suspend give us a
sec
122 all right go you you can proce thank
you Mr Speaker Mr clerk Mr Speaker
frankly I goofed on my uh vote on sorry
can everybody hear me now okay I goofed
on my vote on House Bill 1212 intending
to vote one way but actually voting the
other and I move reconsideration so as
to correct my mistake thank you and I
will ask ask for a division
vote and vote Yes on
reconsideration
all right the question is whether to
reconsider House Bill
1212 and this will be a division vote
members take your seats say
what represent Sweeney request of roll
calls that sufficiently seconded oh sure
this will be a roll call vote members
still take your
seats
C
the question is we whether to reconsider
the last vote on House Bill
1212 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor of Recon uh sorry this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
press the green button opposed press the
red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote
187 in the affirmative 181 in the
negative
reconsideration passes and now we're
back to in expedient to legislate on
House Bill
1212 the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on how Bill
1212 and this will be a division
vote members take your
seats
e
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill 1212 representative Damon
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that hungry children do not learn well
and cost us more in special education
and IEPs would I now vote to feed the
children
and vote red so we can make a better
motion thank
you representative Sween is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the house has already voted on this
measure several times today and in our
earlier wisdom uh just uh earlier this
afternoon if I know we had already
passed this motion would I now press the
green button and pass the motion again
thank you Mr
Speaker
the the question is on in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 1212 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative
man have all members presentence and an
opportunity
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 181 in the affirmative 187 in the
negative the motion
fails for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion Mr Speaker make State
your motion indefinitely postpone I'm
sorry I moveed to indefinitely postpone
house Bill 1212 representative Sweeney
moves at House Bill 1212 be indefinitely
postponed there will be a division vote
members take your
seats
boy we're gotting a lot of mileage out
of this
one the motion is whether to
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1212
representative Damon recognized for a
motion uh for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we want to feed the children so
they can learn well and efficiently
would I now vote red to not indefinitely
postponed so we can make a better
motion the question is whether to
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1212
and it's a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppos press
the red voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 186 in the
negative the motion
fails
for what reason does the member rise to
make a motion oh good we haven't had
nearly enough of those
today well here's one more uh may I
after voting on the prevailing side for
the OTP measure for HB 1212 I'd like to
uh
reconsider or what is it I'd like
to
okay isid
yeah ah parliamentary gymnastics today
so the the motion is
reconsideration on a to pass if this
passes then we then we're back to a to
pass
oky
dokie the motion is whether to
reconsider uh House Bill 1212 again are
you ready for the what division it'll be
a division vote why not members take
your seats if you left them for any
reason
C
the question is reconsideration of House
Bill
1212 this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppose
press the red I'm required to say that
every time I know you're getting good at
it voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote and there have been
plenty of
opportunities the house will attend to
the state of the vote
188 in the affirmative 180 in the
negative reconsideration
passes and now we are back to ought to
pass on House Bill 1212 are you ready
for the
question oh for the love of flap Jacks
okay so did I hear
division
speaker say who requested it
representative Keller requests a roll
call and there are more than 10 people
up this will be a roll call vote members
if you've left take your
seats
your
the motion is out to pass on House Bill
1212 and this is a division
vote I'm sorry you're right that's a
roll call vote I just got so used to
those divisions if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 193 in the
affirmative 175 in the negative the
motion passes House Bill 1212 is
referred to the committee on
finance
the majority of the committee on finance
to which was referred House Bill 1560
fnaa an act relative to unassigned
monies in the education trust fund
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative
papichi Muller for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Mary Heath for the
minority of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of V to pass you ready
for the
question no we have debate hey look at
that we have
debate representative hackin Phillips is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I rise today in
opposition to the a to pass motion for H
B
1560 this bill will take the remaining
balance of the unspent unallocated funds
from the education trust fund at the end
of each fiscal year and move those
Monies to the general
fund currently the education trust fund
balance is about 160 million and it's
projected to grow close to 220 Million
by the end of fiscal 25 under our
current law the current concern
expressed in our committee was that this
sum of designated money sitting in the
education trust fund is otherwise
unavailable to the state so rather than
protecting the education trust fund
balance for educational purposes as the
supreme court ordered in the 1990s and
reaffirmed again this year the sponsors
believe that the state should be given
flexibility to use that money for all
other future competing interests of the
state proponents say that this bill does
not eliminate the fund it just removes
the balance at the end of the year so
the education trust fund is replenished
each year with new Revenue sources so
there's nothing to fear but if there's
nothing to fear then why did Granite
stator sign in 133 to5 in opposition to
this bill why did the New Hampshire Nea
provide testimony against this bill and
why did this bill get rushed through the
committee process that's right hb15 1960
was introduced in house finance on the
morning of January 25th and referred to
division 2 before lunch then after lunch
the work session resulted in a
recommendation of this bill to our full
committee and then 3 days later after a
long session day on February 1st where
members were encouraged to limit
discussion house finance voted 13 to 12
to bring the bill to the floor today
despite the unanswered questions about
the attorney general en's interpretation
of our recent Supreme Court decisions
and our duty as legislators to respond
this begs the question why the rush why
especially when we know that this exact
proposal was stripped out of the
stripped out by the esteemed body behind
the wall during the recent banian budget
negotiations my discussion with members
of that body's education committee is
that no one there is asking for this and
no one's asking for this Rush
Mr Speaker I oppose this bill for three
reasons first the education I'm sorry
educ
emptying the balance in the education
trust fund at the end of the year is not
prudent because of several unknowns
monies in the education trust fund must
be appropriated for a set of open
warrants for things like kind
kindergarten education Freedom accounts
charter schools and core ordered
placements these open warrants are built
into the budget but we don't know how
much we're going to spend year to year
so when things like the education
Freedom account program runs millions of
dollars over budget or the new program
for episodic treatment placements costs
more than anticipated in its first year
additional funding can be asked can be
approved um by going to
the fiscal committee and once authorized
those additional funds must be pulled
from the education trust fund under law
what the problem is is that there's a
history in New Hampshire where when the
fiscal committee has authorized those
additional funds there has not been
enough money in the education trust fund
or the general fund to replenish and
fully pay for those programs that result
is that local taxpayers are on the hook
for part of those shortfalls and those
localities never recover those funds
this is why it's imperative that
protected educational monies and the
education trust fund must stay in the
education trust fund so that monies may
be immediately available to backfill
program
overruns and to lessen the burden our
local taxpayers now we know that local
taxpayers are already bearing the burden
of 80% of New Hampshire's educational
costs and this is absolutely the wrong
move at the exact wrong time second Mr
Speaker I oppose
hb50
1560 because the public is aware of
these new recent Supreme Court rulings
and they're watching us I knocked on
over a thousand doors in the last
election cycle and the number one
constituent issue before my constituents
was to protect public school funding it
was not to drain the education trust
fund the the public is not calling for
this change and we must acknowledge that
emptying the education trust fund will
not reflect the will of the public
as one constituent letter to finance put
it and I quote we all know the state is
shortchanging education and the recent
Supreme Court ruling stated funding
levels should be
doubled end of quote my finance
colleague brilliantly said any attempt
to divert funds from New Hampshire's
education trust fund will send a
damaging message to our constituents
even if we can move money around when we
need it that this will be perceived as
an attack on public educ ation yes
passing this bill will be seen as an
attack on public education at the very
moment we've been ordered by our Supreme
Court to protect it and to spend more
finally Mr
Speaker the house special education
subcommittee has been tasked with the
very question of how to better fund our
Public Schools understanding how much
money is available is a critical input
into determining how much money we have
to spend and emptying the education
trust fund before the subcommittee has
resolved this question is an
irresponsible undermining of their work
and that's why this bill should go to
that subcommittee for these reasons Mr
Speaker I urge you to vote no on the
motion of OTP so that another more
prudent motion may be made thank you Mr
Speaker and I request a division
vote for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion State your motion
I move to table House Bill
1560 representative Wier moves at House
Bill 1560 be laid on the table are you
ready for the
question and division this will be a
division vote members take your
seats
pi
e
good
clear
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 1560 on the table and this is a
division
vote
okie
dokie if you're in favor of tbling press
the green button oppos press the red
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 346 in the affirmative and the
proud bipartisan 14 and the
negative the motion is
adopted
never
Flor
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 1589 FN an act
establishing a veterans treatment Court
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment Senor Bob Lynn for the
committee
the amendment is
0334 printed in house record 6 Pages 35-
36 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is
adopted Bill's open to SEC on second
reading open to further
Amendment representative steton office
floor Amendment
0671 the chair recognizes representative
Stapleton
thank you uh Mr
chair speaker
sorry um 1589 out of Judiciary um bill
for uh a veteran treatment courts um
passed otpa 18 to Zer bipartisan but the
amendment the
0334 was only approved on a 13-5 and the
reason for that was some missing
language in the
U definition of
veteran um there were like five pieces
of the definition the piece that was
problematic was in Roman 3 on page one
in d
section and it had written originally
and in the 0334 Amendment a current or
former military member of a fr foreign
Allied country without further
qualification now it's important to
qualify that
because we had people working under our
Command in combat
areas and in coal and working in Co
Coalition with Coalition
forces so my Amendment adds the missing
language that says a a current or former
military member of a foreign Allied
country who was attached to or under
command of United States forces or
Coalition forces therewith in a combat
operations engagement this is a
reciprocal um orientation for this
because we have had people um support us
who could no longer remain in their
country um political Asylum and those
have become citizens
and that recognizes they performed
valuable service to uh our country as uh
other veterans uh U that had done so so
I'm asking for you to help us clean that
up and approve uh this uh amendment to
provide the additional
language motion before us is stap
Stapleton floor Amendment 0671 are you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in fa say I I those oppos nay
the eyes have it and the STA in floor
amendment is adopted the motion before
it's now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it in the committee report as
amended as adopted and it's going to
finance and it's going to
finance there's no debate on this
but
the committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 1696 an act relative
to electronic record requests under the
right to no law considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill had to pass with Amendment pres of
Joe Alexander for the committee the
amendment is 02 37h printed in house
record 6 page 38 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it amendment is adopted s of
Granger has asked for a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded it's not sufficiently
seconded the motion before us say ought
to pass with Amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say
iose nay the eyes have it and the
committee report is
adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
the Senate concurs with the house in the
passage of the following entitled bill
with amendment in the passage of which
amendment the Senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 154
relative to electronic ballot counting
[Music]
devices
representative turot requests that we
non-c Concur and form a committee of
conference chair recognizes
representative
Barry thank you Mr Speaker um the Senate
made significant changes to House Bill
154 uh it was referred out of our body
as a municipal and County bill it has
been a turned into an election law bill
um I have reviewed this bill I've
reviewed this bill in consult
consultation with the ranking member and
the Secretary of State there is no
reason to have a COC on this bill
there's been no proposed changes to this
bill um this bill is good to go so I
would kindly ask that the body vote down
the motion for committee of conference
so that another motion may be
made you I recognize repent
turot lend herot thank you Mr
Speaker as the
previous speaker just mentioned this
bill came back from the Senate it was
originally a house uh house Municipal
and County government bill our committee
um the Senate changed it and turned it
into a very
lengthy um election law Bill uh the
individual on the other side of the wall
who's also Municipal and County
Government uh is uh Municipal and county
is also election law um the bill was put
onto one of our bills uh a uh a section
of our rsas I know very little
about uh we were uh this bill was dumped
in our laps and uh it was determined
with the individual on the other side of
the wall that we would request a
committee a conference I will say
however you just heard the chairman of
el election
law uh make his case and I would suggest
you
all think about that thank you Mr
chairman there we the mo the mo the
motion before us is to form a committee
of conference on House Bill
154 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I those
[Applause]
opposed motion
fails repres representative Barry is
recognized yes
ma'am representative Barry makes a
motion that we concurr and is recognized
to speak to his motion uh yep I don't
need to speak to it but you've said my
motion so I'm all set thank you
oh I'm sorry I'm supposed to talk about
what the changes are yes so the changes
are extensive um what basically What's
Happening Here is the bout law
commission has been in a I want to say I
don't know six-year review process on
replacing our aging ACU vote machines so
we have approved two new machines um and
we are this bill is a housekeeping Bill
to change B basically our current rsas
are all written around the acuo machines
they're written about around how the
acuo machines work so everything in this
is just changing it so an example is one
of the machines reads squares our RSA
says ovals so it's things like that to
housekeeping bill it's not substantively
changing how we operate our elections or
anything like that it's just clearing
the way for this process that has been o
over the last six years so with that I
would ask that the body move to concur
with House Bill 154 the motion before us
is the current House Bill 154 are ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the motion
passes majority of the committee on
legislative Administration which was
referred House Bill 1000 an act relative
to classifying New Hampshire legislative
Service as public service for certain
federal purposes consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Michael
Constable from the
majority minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Allison nning
Wong for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
Reed
thank you Mr
Speaker in 2007 under the George W Bush
Administration the federal government
started the Public service loan
forgiveness program whereby in order to
encourage young people to enter Public
Service which frequently doesn't pay as
much um the federal government if you
serve in public service for 10 years and
make ontime payments on your student
loans for those 10 years you would get
the remainder of your federal student
loans
forgiven I think I I hope that no one
would argue that
we offer Public Service I hope we're all
here to serve the
public it turns out almost every other
state certifies their state legislators
as public servants for the purposes of
this program virtually every other state
most of which are part-time
ncsl was consulted to ask which of these
states and we could only find two that
didn't virtually every other state
certifies public service for their state
legislators some of them are so
part-time that they only serve one out
of every two
years the decision on whether to certify
our public service is a decision of this
body like it has been for every other
state in addition the commissioner of
the Department of administrative
Services has repeatedly said that he is
fine in support certifying our Public
Service as a donor State our New
Hampshire federal tax dollars instead of
going to forgive some of the public the
the public loans for our state
legislators is going to
forgive the student loans of
Massachusetts state reps California
state reps New York State reps but not
our own we desperately need young people
in this chamber we desperately need
fresh blood newer ideas and we Beman the
fact that we have a graying problem in
New Hampshire and in this
chamber this body is significantly older
and significantly different in many ways
than the average New Hampshire citizens
and so in order to encourage young
people to
serve we can certify our public service
without costing the state a single
dime as was the intention of that
program so I ask you to overturn the itl
and support OTP on
this CH recognize represent of
con does a member yield to
questions I
do member Mo
inquire thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you for taking my question uh I know
that we've heard a a lot that uh we are
supposedly not employees for the
purposes of the state but isn't it true
that the federal government does
consider us
employees thank you for the question it
is indeed true that even though we often
say that while our salary was set in the
Constitution we're not employees of the
State uh the federal government doesn't
seem to care too much about that because
as we all just recently got our W2s W2s
you can look them up are only given to
employees in addition we pay taxes
federal taxes Medicaid and Social
Security taxes out of those W2 so the
federal government does indeed consider
us employees of um consider us employees
in addition the Ein the employer
identification number that is on our W2s
that's how the federal government
determines whether or not your employer
qualifies as public service that Ein
which is
02600 618 is the same Ein as every every
state employee in this state Department
of Transportation uh education you name
it every single employee has the same
Ein that we do and that Ein is
considered public service by the federal
government furthermore even though we
are elected we have state employees who
are hired and fired through election or
in reelection including the Secretary of
State the treasurer and the clerk all of
which do qualify for Public service loan
forgiveness we've already extended in
legislation um things like health
insurance benefits to the body because
we can acknowledge that we're not
employees for the purposes of the state
while still extending those benefits
this is just another extension of
benefits we still wouldn't be considered
employees by the state but the federal
government already considers employees
so it's just an extension of those
benefits and it costs us
nothing J recognize representative
crossable thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of the committee report of it in
hp1000
so there seems to be what the proponents
of this bill would want to do is
to make a gray area of what we are in
terms of employees in terms of full-time
and um it's it's not a gray area for
me are you elected or are we employees
of the state it's that simple yes or no
the answer is no we are elected the $200
W2 I would argue is a reason that um
maybe we should look into re um
addressing that clerical error it does
not mean we employees of the
state another point of this is that on
average for the two-year term you would
you would have needed to work 30 hours
per week how many of you in July and
August will attest that you've been here
30 hours per week on any given it is for
the whole it is not for the six months
that you're here it's for the whole
year um we so and we've never been
considered a full-time legislature
everyone says we are a volunteer
part-time citizen legislature okay so to
bend the rules to fit into this Federal
program to me is is
wrong um part one section one Roman
numeral one of our ethics guidelines
it's the first thing you read in your
ethics guidelines and I'll paraphrase
I'm not going to read it exactly is that
we in this body should use our power and
resource for the general interest of the
State of New Hampshire and not to attain
personal benefits I there's no good
argument to say that a personal benefit
of loan forgiveness is in the general
interest of this state it's just simply
not true it is a personal benefit that
we should not be voting for
ourselves it also begs the
question how many of us have student
loans in this body that would be
possibly subject to the the windfall
here um and I would look forward to the
the uh letters of intent uh to
participate on whether or not we we we
hold student loans and should we even be
allowed to vote on on that sort of
thing
um the the last thing I'll bring up real
quick is this pushes the attestation of
of certifying that we are full-time
public employees not on us but onto the
general Administration and and some
people may have said they okay with that
but go but but you're pushing under
penalty of perjury on on this Pro
program onto the administrative staff
and not onto the person that is saying
that um they're they're full-time and so
for all four of these reasons I would
ask you to support the committee of itl
thank you Mr Speaker does the member
yield to
questions
sure member yields say will leave May
inquire I want to thank my friend from
legislative
Administration this mic needs to be
turned up a bit I think I don't know
thank you my friend from legislative
Administration my question to you is uh
you said Sheriff uh elected officials
are not employees would that include
sheriffs of the counties are would they
be considered
employees um yes but I I would note that
this isn't all of the above it's not one
or the other and if you like I said it
is not just employees even if you bought
into the W 2 argument you still have to
claim the 30 hours per week for for the
full two-year term for the full two
years and even if you could claim a
certain number of weeks during that
six-month period that we're here I think
would be a stretch you you still need
both of those together thank you for the
answer Reed has requested a roll call I
mean a uh division vote uh members take
your seats division division
vote represent Sweeney has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded representative Granger has
requested a roll call it is sufficiently
seconded
e
the motion before
us is the majority of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1000 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representer marjerie Smith for a
parliamentary
inquiry
M Mr
Speaker if I
know that given all the responsibilities
we in this legislature
have it does not
include
interpreting for the federal government
what the federal government should or
should do and if I know that in
virtually every
state the states that meet 90
days in a year the states that meet 90
days in two years the states that meet
every other year in practically every
state in the United
States this program is available for
legislators who are paid at rates That
Vary dramatically and the federal
government responsible for this
program have agreed to that
eligibility not something that we have
to worry about that's for them to worry
about and if I
know that just today I heard about one
of our wonderful colleagues who is not
going to be able to run again next year
depriving us of that
experience because of the problems of
trying to pay back loans and if I know
to be eligible you have to have been you
have to have been in the program paying
for 10 years once a
month and if I know I said it I thought
that you have to be have paid for 10
years made a 100 20 payments on time
following the requirements before you
could be com con considered for this and
if I know that with all those
protections and with the federal
government not being overly
generous they have managed to approve
this for every other state would I now
say that New Hampshire legislators
should be entitled to the same benefits
that other legisl are across the country
and therefore would you vote no on itl
so that another motion could be made
thank you do recognize repres
Representative Steven Pearson for a
parliamentary
inquir thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know members of the general court
have never been considered employees as
required by the provisions of this
Federal
program and if I know to qualify for for
this program The General Court
Administration would be required to
certify to the federal government under
penalty of perjury that a given
representative or Senator worked
full-time averaging 30 hours per week
for the entire two-year term and lastly
Mr Speaker if I know that a
representative or Senator would be
receiving a personal benefit that would
most likely not be available to our
constituents what I press the green
button to support the committee
recommendation thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us a majority
commited report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1000 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppose
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
wood
all members present at an opportunity to
vote house will attend to say to the
vote 184 voting a 174 voting a the
committee report is
adopted majority committee on
legislative Administration to which was
referred House Bill
1219 act relative to creating a
commission to study the feasability and
structure of a legislative
office to provide longitudinal cost
benefit analysis of significant proposed
legislation on the budgetary revenue
estimates considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that as inexpedient to
legislate representative Hill for the
majority of the committee minority the
committee having considered this the
same and being unable to agree with a
majority Report with a recommendation
the bill ought to pass Senate bison not
even long from the minority of the
committee chair recognize representative
Aly thank you Mr
Speaker this bill is to create a
shortterm
commission until November and that's it
of six leg legislators half from each
party one person each from the LBA and
Dr and three New Hampshire economists
with budget and revenue and economic
impact experience selected by the head
of our
lbo the purpose is to develop a bill to
add nonpartisan Dynamic analysis to our
state's fiscal
tollbox on we are confident that we can
assemble a team quickly enough to comp
complete the work by the November
deadline this economics tool can be very
useful for our decision making on
financial issues we sometimes have
attractive bills for new programs that
would require new expenditures the
sponsors say they will pay for
themselves if in the end if only by
making the workforce healthier or more
qualified but is that really true and
will it take decades or years to pay it
back
that question is what kept us from
passing adult dental care for 15
years the basic tool is an unbiased
econometric model which has been
developed over 40 years feeding in data
from changes made in many states we
would use it to create a model of how
our own State economy works that would
be used to project the change proposed
by a bill
which on W what that bill would do five
10 20 years out if we passed
it changes to our employment our wage
levels our education levels Health costs
revenues expenditures whatever factors
we feel are the most important the model
is the
infrastructure the building of our own
model selection of a local operator and
choice of which proposals to submit to
it yearly would be up to
us the econ economics team behind the
national model would help the local
operator learn the model and adapt it to
our state the team I have observed over
the last few years has worked with red
States and blue States they produce
external Revenue estimates and other
special projects for many states and
their
subsidiaries cities and
counties the New Hampshire Department of
Employment Security already has this
special unit which is the one that has
been producing the really good
employment analysis we've been seeing
these past two year two
terms the value of this tool is not in
telling us what to do it is in providing
an outside voice to put beh beside our
current sources of information but a
voice that has been trained to look
longitudinally over
overtime
forecasting we have an incredibly good
Revenue Department but when it estimates
the business taxes and the interest in
dividends for us it bases its decisions
on three-year-old
numbers because it will not go past hard
facts even the comprehensive annual
financial report of the state is not
hard fact because audits on individual
tax spares have not yet been
completed we in Ways and Means need both
s sources to combine with our own
estimates as my distinguished colleague
from Hudson always says we need Dynamic
analysis analysis that both parties can
have confidence in I hope you will allow
this bipartisan commission with experts
to go forward so we can bring you a
proposal that best suits our state
thank
you chair recogniz representative
Hill thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker the only word the
bipartisan majority of the committee
took issue with in this bill was the
word
commission the bill as introduced tries
to squeeze a complicated commission into
the month prior to the November deadline
in an election year
and we felt that it would likely produce
poor results we felt a much better plan
for the desired outcome would be an ad
hoc group meeting now beginning now with
a goal of submitting a bill to the
finance committee with appropriate
funding for a pilot program with a third
party doing the longer term modeling
please support the committee
recommendation
the motion before us a majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl on House Bill
1219 a division has been requested
members take your
seats
e
the motion before us a majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legisl and House Bill 1219 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that we're
all elected every two years and if I
believe that having a commission to
consider how to take a careful and
considerate look at our state's
long-term needs and Trends so they can
advise the legislature of them would I
now press the red button so another
motion can be made and the itl can be
overturned chair recognized
representative Hill for a pement inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know
that longer term studies would seem to
be a valuable tool for a few select
bills during this budgeting year and I
know that the finance committee could
examine a bill next year to fund a pilot
program with a third-party team who does
this modeling and lastly Mr Speaker if I
know it is very unlikely that a
meaningful report could be generated by
November of this and election year by
the time individuals are identified and
appointed Mr Mr Speaker would I press
the green button to support the
committee report of
itl the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1219 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e
all members president an opportunity to
vote also tend to sayate the
vote 178 voting a 173 voting a committee
report is
adopted majority committee on
legislative Administration to which was
referred House Bill 1363 FN in Act
relative to
allowing members of the general court to
participate in the Department of Health
and Human Services employee assistant
program considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate Senor Michael costable for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with the majority
Report with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass sen Allison n and
Wong for the minority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those opposed
nay the division has been called for
clarification only members in the room
can
vote
the motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate motion on House Bill 1363
this is a clarification vote this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
for
[Music]
represent
Griffin
all members present have an opportunity
to vote househ tend to stay to the
vote 169 voting aay 174 voting aay the
motion
fails i' move on to
pass Weber moves ought to
pass
[Music]
represent requested representative rulu
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
vote this gets overturned fin this
passes it fin
the motion before us is a to pass pass
and House Bill 1363
FN this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppose you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
RS times
CH all members president an opportunity
to
vote house will attend to state of the
vote 184 voting yay 168 voting nay
committee report of autop pass is
adopted and it is on its way to
finance committee on science technology
and energy to which was referred House
Bill
1576 FN act relative to allowing
Property Owners to opt out of Public
Utilities considered the same report the
same with the following resolution that
is inexpedient to
legislate representative Michael VES for
the committee the motion before us is
any expedient to legislator are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I oppose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted
wait
that's
priority majority the committee on state
and federal Elations and Veterans
Affairs to which was referred
hcr8 the house will be in order to get
an awful lot
an act applying to Congress for a
limited national Convention for the
exclusive purpose of proposing an
amendment to the United States
Constitution relative to elections been
considered the same report the same on
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass from pres of Tom Manion for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having been considered the same being
unold agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate
represenative Chris Sebert for the
minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion State your motion
I would like to table this house
resolution that is a priority motion the
motion before us is to table
hcr8 are you ready for the question all
those in favor
say is that a roll call to or
just a division vote has been called
members take your
seats
C
the motion before us is the table
hcr8 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative grer thank you
Mr Speaker uh if I know that I want to
get home today would I vote in favor of
the tabling motion thank you chair
recognizes representative new for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I uh if
I know that this house is a place where
we debate um things that are worthy of a
debate and that this is uh something
that is contentious and should be heard
would I now push the red button not to
table this
motion the motion before us is the table
house hcr8 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
[Music]
represent
Sullivan
representative
boy all members president had an
opportunity to vote I'll attend to stay
to the
vote 230 20 147 voting yay 99 voting nay
hcr8 is laid on the
table committee on state and federal
relations and veter Affairs to which was
referred
hcr1 condemning medically unnecessary
restrictions on medication
abortion representative cybert moves
ought to pass the chair recognizes
representative
Simon thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker language is a
powerful
tool with it we can use words to
construct ideas invoke emotions activate
the imagination and shape not only the
way millions of people think but also
what they believe that a well-crafted
message can accomplish this is evidenced
by the existence of a multi-billion
dollar marketing
industry
hcr1 and abortion messaging in general
gives us a master class in this with
just a few simple phrases suborders have
been able to effectively shape the
conversation and in many cases have
captured people's imagination around
this issue for example they say that
abortion is safe essential reproductive
Health Care a private medical decision
between a mother and her
physician these are all attractive
propositions that when taken at face
value I would agree with wouldn't
you now as this resolution puts it
abortion is essential to protecting an
individual's freedom to control their
own body life and future it's an
appealing conceit that uh one could
actually control these things after all
life is full of dangers and difficulties
it's riddled by fears and uncertainty
and in it there is no lack of pain toil
or
tragedy if abortion could actually
eliminate these problems then abortion
would afford a kind of freedom to those
who get one that has otherwise been
unknown to
mankind without question abortion would
not only be a good but one might argue
it would even border on the
miraculous so if that was the actual
reality of abortion then I wouldn't
oppose
it however I've never been able to shake
off the idea that these statements do
not accurately reflect what an abortion
is that perhaps these phrases are simply
empty
platitudes for amidst all the carefully
crafted language of hcr1 a document that
is designed to appeal to our sense of
empathy and fairness it seems to me that
there is very one very small but
significant detail missing the direct
object of the
abortion the human
child the human child that is the result
of the reproduction that has already
occurred so if a human child is the
result of reproduction and abortion is
the ending of that very same
reproduction then I'm left with this
haunting
thought are we killing innocent human
children to solve our
problems are we killing innocent human
children to mitigate the dangers and
difficulties of Life are we killing
innocent children to assuage our fears
and uncertainties are we killing
innocent children under the
misconception that it has the power to
remove pain and toil from our
futures Mr Speaker I'm convinced that
the answer to these questions is a
resounding yes when I look at this
resolution every word seems to confirm
it it jumps out at me from every line
one of the central tenants of hdr1 seems
to be that abortion is necessary to
avoid poverty and hardship and ensure an
unencumbered life defined by Pleasure
even even if this were true which it
isn't tell me is this all that it means
to be human looking into our past
starting with our own parents and
Tracing Our Family Lines back to the
dawn of humanity is there anyone here
who can say with any level of confidence
that there was no one in your family
history who ever endured poverty so that
you could be here
today that none of them ever sacrificed
when it was inconvenient that none of
them delayed pleasure or for seasons of
their life encumbered themselves for the
sake of their
descendants aren't we Greatful ful for
this don't we honor them for the
sacrifices that they made of which we
are the
beneficiaries don't we owe this same
life-giving selflessness to the Next
Generation but some will say surely
these people are too little to actually
be people then let me ask you when do we
come when do we become people when do we
cease to be a potential medical
procedure for our
mothers Mr Speaker here is what I know
I know that when my father's sperm and
my mother's egg connected in that
literal flash of light my life began
just as yours did for you did it
not if within weeks of that moment your
light had been snuffed out what would
that have meant for you would you have
just been put on some sort of pause as
though ready to join the world people
suddenly told you oh not yet we're not
ready for you yet so you simply hung
around the waiting room until your
mother got pregnant again at a
convenient
time or would you just be
de the next time your mother got
pregnant if we sought for you would we
have found you or would the child who
emerged from the womb be a totally
different
person I do not oppose abortion out of
any desire to control women's bodies or
to insert myself into the legitimate
medical decisions that occur between a
woman and her
doctor but I will stand up and speak
when I read that 5 million women have
used this abortion medication which the
resolution describes as safe and
effective and I know it has caused the
death of at least one person every time
it has been used when I know in fact
that that is its very
purpose I stand up here knowing that I
will once again have to endure cold
shoulders eye rolls angry tweets
character assassination attempts and
calls from my seat but these things are
less than nothing to me because when I
look into the depth of my daughter's
eyes I see my children's Children's
children's children and with them
myriads of others Mr Speaker I can see
them but not now now I can behold them
but not near nevertheless the glory of
God their creator shines upon them from
generation to generation and in the
warmth of his love and light I love them
so I
stand Mr Speaker as a member of this
house and therefore as a person who has
been endowed with authority and Mr
Speaker as someone who has been asked to
give my support to a resolution that
calls it a good to direct the power of
the sword in the form of a pill against
those of us too young to have ever done
anything good or evil paying the price
for our problems with their lives will
we declare without equivocation or shame
that we will build a better world on the
mountain of their dead
bodies what choice do I have Mr Speaker
other than to ethically and emphatically
vote no I urge my colleagues to press
the red button that a better motion be
can be made thank you you recognize repr
Simpson
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in support
of hcr1 a resolution condemning
medically unnecessary restrictions on
mistone the first pill of medication
abortion in 1991 New Hampshire was the
first state in the country to pass a
resolution which was also
hcr1 urging the usfda to conduct
clinical trials on mistone and to
encourage its use due to the significant
medical value
this was a bipartisan vote because as we
know New Hampshire has enjoyed for so
long broad bipartisan support for
abortion I introduced this resolution
because of the significant threat we
face right now as a country including
here in New Hampshire the US Supreme
Court has its first abortion case since
they overturned roie Wade and the
decision is expected in June the case
was brought forward by anti-abortion
activists and could remove m stoned from
the market everywhere including in
states where abortion is legal like here
in New
Hampshire the case ignores science and
is entirely based on anti-abortion bias
in fact just last week two studies cited
as justification to restrict mistone
were
retracted here are the facts since the
FDA approved mistone over 20 years ago 5
million people in the United States have
used mistone a prescribed drug a
prescribed drug for a variety of
purposes mistone is the first pill of
medication abortion and is only
available up until the 11th week of a
pregnancy mistone is also used for
miscarriage management we continue to
hear stories of women in states where
abortion is banned being unable to get
miscarriage care because the medication
mistone is the same one that is used for
abortion we should not have Granite
Staters facing those same
threats another use of myth aistone the
one mentioned in a committee report as
something we can all agree on for
today's vote is for ectopic
pregnancies but I want to be clear the
US Supreme Court's upcoming decision
will impact M mistone overall not pick
and choose which medical procedures are
available in other words patients who
have an ectopic pregnancy can be
affected by the Supreme Court
case Mya prisone is extremely safe safer
than Tylenol for example it is effective
and its approval should not be affected
by the whims of Bad actors across the
country we should oppose these tactics
to pass a deao nationwide abortion ban
if mistone is banned the results could
have major implications that go far
beyond abortion care we should all be
able to agree that one judge in Texas
shouldn't have the authority to
undermine the entire drug approval
system we have the opportunity today to
send a message to Washington but even
more important to send a message to our
constituents where do we as the New
Hampshire house stand on medication
abortion do we support abortion early in
pregnancy specifically abortion up until
the 11th week if we do the vote is easy
and we pass this resolution in a strong
bipartisan
vote I've heard many many colleagues
speak about our current abortion ban
promising not to change it today all of
us can demonstrate that we will fight
against restrictions on abortion early
in pregnancy we can show that we'll do
everything in our power as a legislature
to protect Granite State patients who
need medication abortion health care for
uterine fibroids medication for
miscarriage management and a critical
medication for ectopic
pregnancies I urge you to join me and
support the ought to pass motion on
hcr1 and Mr Speaker I request a roll
call
vote the motion before us is autop pass
on HCR of 11 representative Simpson has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
roll call
vote
e
C
motion before us is aut to pass on hcr1
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative pendil for
parliamentary
inquiry Mr
Speaker if I know that the committee
attempted to amend hcr1 to support the
use of Mi Prestone as medically
indicated for use in ectopic pregnancy
certain uterine anomalies or large
fibroids if I know that mistone used
with the intention of causing an
abortion has an almost 100% fatality
rate to the child in
utero if I know that 4 million women
have been convinced to take this drug
because they bought the
lie that if allowed The Gift of Life
their children would prevent them from
equal participation in Social and
economic life
if I know that prescribing miffa pyone
to survivors of rape and domestic
violence to avoid detection protects the
perpetrator from detection and
Punishment and if I know that the
legislature should oppose the
weaponization of resolutions that seek
to tip the scales of Justice in distant
circuit courts would I now vote to
overturn the a to pass motion and press
the red
button do you recognize cber for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that hcr1
is in line with what this body did in
1991 when they passed a resolution to
urge the FDA to conduct clinical trials
for mea Prestone due to its significant
medical value and if I know that the
Supreme Court US Supreme Court currently
has a case that could take myth Prestone
off the market including here in New
Hampshire and if I know that myth
Prestone is also used for uterine
fibroids upep topic pregnancies
miscarriage management and medication
abortion only up until the 11th week of
pregnancy and finally Mr Speaker if I
know the decision would affect patients
that need to have access to life-saving
healthc care would I now press the green
button and vote to pass
hcr1 thank you motion before us is a to
pass on hcr1 it's a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
representative
sagus
all members president an opportunity to
vote Al attend to stay to the
vote 196 voting yay 151 voting nay the
motion of autop pass
passes Mr Speaker committee on state for
what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I would move to take House Bill
1419 off the
table
motion is in order the motion is to take
House
Bill house
PR
okay House Bill
1419 from the table division has been
requested members take your seats this
will be a division
vote
all right the motion before us is to
remove House Bill 1419 from the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppos you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative Allison
turov you can't push the button I need
to thank
you representative
[Music]
rbo represent Maier
representative
Andre
Gorski represent
Melvin
while MERS president opportunity to vote
also tend to stay to the
vote 308 voting yay 40 voting nay the
motion before us now is ought to
pass the question is ought to
pass was ought to pass the pending
question the motion the motion before us
is ought to pass s going to ask for a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call
vote we had a
debate
debate we have a
debate we we cut off the debate it
back the motion before us is ought to
pass we had a debate that debate was cut
off so we're going back to the debate so
the chair recognizes representative
Tanner
thank you Mr
Speaker this bill
1419 is about prohibiting obscene and
harmful sexual materials in school when
it comes to literature and education
historically no theme is safe from
censorship books from serious to Violent
to Fantasy have all been under the knife
for of censorship like to Kill a Mocking
Bird the Diary of a young girl by Anne
Frank
1984 and Huckleberry Finn have all been
censored at one time certain words
phrases or selected passages of a sexual
nature and especially about lesbian gay
bisexual transgender black indigenous
and people of color are often those
singled out as
objectionable it is already illegal to
distribute OB seen material to miners a
felony under RSA 50 colon 2 educators
are not exempt from this law but receive
an added layer of due process due to the
nature of their work which may involve
areas like sex education instruction art
and
literature Educators found guilty of
disturbing of Distributing materials
that the court has determined to be
obscene are guilty of
felony legal issues with criminal and
monetary fines should be left up to the
judicial system I want to make it
perfectly clear that educators are not
exempt from the current
law hb1 1419 sets up a parallel process
to challenge materials at the local
level that is overly prescriptive and
may be
unworkable it has vague standards and
arbitrary and stringent deadlines lines
the vague standards required in this
process are determined by whether the
identified materials quote predominantly
appeal to aent interest unquote and
quote lack serious literary scientific
medical artistic or political value
unquote the amount of time it takes
especially for high volumes of
simultaneous challenges often results in
multiple School Personnel reading the
book or material in its entirety
teachers and staff do this using
additional time on top of their normally
assigned School duties timelines will be
difficult at best to
meet hb1
1419 makes the State Board of Education
the final Arbiter to judge not the
process but the decision of quote
Community standards it is fundamental
that local community standards should be
determined by the locally elected school
board by using the local school district
policies and
procedures school boards are close to
the community whose standards they are
representing and directly accountable to
their constituents at The Ballot Box the
appointed state board of education is
not school districts should and do have
policies and procedures in place and
these policies and procedures need to
ensure due process to meet parents
concerns in a timely manner and in a
balanced way they should preserve local
control and insurance compliance with
non-discrimination
laws professionally trained Librarians
and educators are valuable resources to
help parents find interesting
informative and age appropriate
materials for their children they work
collaboratively with parents to
encourage reading and discussing places
topics and ideas parents can remove
their child from classes course material
curriculum books and media material at
school Under current law and they have
the responsibility of deciding what
media materials are best for their child
they have the right and the
responsibility to review what their
child is reading seeing on the internet
receiving on their cell phones or other
material other parents might make
different decisions have different
perspectives and beliefs and these
decisions and choices should be equally
respected censorship can have serious
and dangerous
consequences growing up is hard
especially today with all the outside
noise and social media kids that are Mar
marginalized or feel different often
become isolated and believe they are the
only ones who feel as they do do they
think that no one else is going through
or experiencing what they are they feel
alone fearful of rejection and often
succumb to
depression erasing the existence voice
and experiences of students who are
lesbian gay bisexual transgender or
questioning students survivors of
violence and abuse and black indigenous
and students of color by censoring
materials in their schools and libraries
takes away their
Humanity respect and
self-esteem it is important to provide
books and materials that open a window
on the world for all students so they
can see themselves in a future where
they can be their authentic self I urge
you to vote how do I urge you to vote
against the OTP thank
you what's this huh I'm
good J recognize representative
Noble I'm sorry does a member yield to a
question does a member yield to a
question no she does not
yield thank you Mr
Speaker back back in 2020 the ACLU
deputy director for transgender Justice
led the charge to ban the book
irreversible damage he said stopping the
circulation of this book and these ideas
is 100% a hill I will die
on caving to the pressure from the
movement against this book Target
promptly removed it from their
shelves Amazon refused to run ads for
the book's publisher and the American
book sellers Association apologized for
their violent distribution of the
book a few years ago the family of Dr
Seuss found themselves posthumously
defending him against claims that he was
racist after significant pressure the
publisher ultimately decided to stop
producing six of his
books last week the Congressional
weaponization committee released what is
being referred to as the Amazon
files which showed that the Biden
Administration was pressuring Amazon to
censor books they disapproved of this
after we had already learned that they
were colluding with big Tech to censor
speech they disapproved
of now that I've presented these
examples of actual book Banning and the
direction from which that comes let's
focus on our Public School
libraries we've had several book
challenges over the years many of which
do not even compare to the books now
being
discovered each time I'm shown a book it
gets
worse in a book called queer a graphic
history there are cartoon-like
depictions of threesoms bondage and SATA
masochism in a book called let's talk
about it young readers are encouraged to
visit online adult chat rooms and to
watch
porn the book says a great place to
research fantasies and Kinks safely is
on the
internet there are tons of people in
communities out there who share your
interests and have all kinds of
advice the online world is also choca
block full of
pornography professionals and amateurs
alike sharing their sexy Adventures
online and it goes on to say there's
nothing wrong with enjoying some porn
it's a fun sugary
treat the book also encourages the young
reader to take and send dirty pictures
including the advice that before you
start sending your naughty
masterpieces around the world take some
time to get friendly with photo editing
software or
apps I'm fairly certain that parents are
assuming the exact opposite of this is
being taught to their
children these books are in New
Hampshire Public High School libraries
along with many others promoting sexual
assault rape cutting suicide
prostitution drug and alcohol use and
more the majority of students in high
school are minors some as young as
14 as a society we have always protected
the innocence of minors
always those opposed to this bill say it
would violate A Child's First Amendment
rights to restrict them from reading the
sexually explicit books in their school
libraries those opposed to this bill
argue that kids need a wide variety of
material sure but does it have to be
obscene would they object to the book I
mentioned earlier irreversible damage
being part of a high school's
collection there is no campaign in New
Hampshire to ban these books no one has
gone after Target or Amazon to stop
selling them no one is trying to stop
the Publishers from producing them that
would be book
Banning these books are available for
any parent to purchase for their
child defense of this material reflects
poorly on our Public Schools the text
and images would get you banned on
social media for violating Community
standards parents and taxpayers being
asked every year to shoulder a heavier
tax burden for their schools need to be
able to trust these
institutions many districts have a
reconsideration policy but this bill
would allow a neutral set of eyes to
consider an appeal from parents I urge
you to support it and Mr Speaker I
request a roll call
vote we already have a roll call the
motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 1419 this is a roll call vote
members take your
seats
e
C
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill
1419 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizer representative
Paige for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I look around this
chamber at my colleagues of all
political
stripes and believe that no member of
this body
supports the dissemination of harmful
materials to our
children but if I know that this
bill creates a vague standard for
defining obscenity using highly
subjective determinations of materials
appropriateness and if I understand that
this bill is built around a fundamental
contradiction that we Define the term
harmful to minors based on prevailing
Community
standards but that our locally elected
boards who are accountable to their
voters at The Ballot Box no longer have
the say
here Mr Speaker if I believe that it is
entirely inappropriate that a group of
political appointees on the State Board
of Education get to tell my community
what our own Community standards
are and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that this body will have the opportunity
to consider bipartisan
legislation that addresses the concerns
around due process for parents raising
concerns while still preserving local
control then would I press the red
button so a better motion may be made
thank
you you recognize represent cello for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that HB
1419 has been
misrepresented as a book Banning bill
because real book Banning involves the
government completely suppressing
material and making it unobtainable by
anyone anywhere something that this bill
does not do if I know that hb1 1419
employs an objective standard for
identifying materials that are harmful
to Miners and that this legal precedent
provides clear guidelines that have been
used in courts for over 50 years and
that this bill also includes a minimum
process by which parents can object to
material if I I was
disturbed by the
examples that have been
given and the words that were just read
from books currently held in public
school libraries if I know that students
go to school to learn and if I believe
that they learn nothing of any value
from this type of
material would I now protect Children's
Mental Health from harm and press the
green button
thank you Mr Speaker the motion before
us is a to pass on House Bill 1419 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote I'll attend to stay the
vote 162 voting a 187 voting a the
motion of autop pass fails Mr to member
rise uh I'd like to move to indefinitely
postpone thank you and vote uh a roll
call
vote the motion before us is
indefinitely postponed on
1419 pres Miler has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call
vote
clear
the motion before us is definitely
postpone on House Bill
1419 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
V representative
V
[Music]
all members president and opportunity to
vote how tend stay the
vote 18 187 voting aay 162 voting nay HB
1419 is indefinitely postponed for what
reason does a member
rise having voted on the prevailing side
I move reconsideration of house bill
1419 and urge my colleagues to vote
no
that is a improper
motion committee on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs to which
was referred hr19 calling for the repeal
of the Jones act this is without
recommendation Senate mfet moves ought
to pass chair recognizer represent of
Harrington thank you Mr Speaker I know
it's late so I'm going to make this
really fast uh I'm going to start by let
opening up with Trinidad and member will
suspend for a minute what is Trinidad
the member will suspend for a minute
it's getting awful awful noisy in here
again this is the last bill on the
regular calendar and we got one more
after that so let's see if we can keep
the chatter down and get through these
next two bills remember may continue
thank you again Trinidad and Tobago just
hold that in your thought for a second
you're going to say what does that have
to do with the Jones act I'll let other
people explain more about the
technicalities of the Jones act but
trenidad and Tobago is where we get our
liquefied natural gas from LNG it's the
only place that New England can get it
from and that terminal in Everett looks
like it's going to stay open for quite
some time now but it has to get filled
the problem is because of the Jones act
we can only get it from one place if
there was no Jones act we could get
domestic LNG from Maryland much shorter
trip it would cost less money or we
could get it from the Gulf Coast where
again domestic uh LNG uh and it would be
a plentiful Supply that we could get
huge amounts of not never having to
worry about a supply issue but the Jones
act says this doesn't work it has to be
a spefic specific ship built in the
United States and manned by American
Crews and they just do not exist there's
no option here they do not exist and no
one's going to build one just to bring
LNG to New England so if something
happens to Trinidad and Tobago in the
winter and we have a severe cold snap we
might not be able to get our LNG and
that means we could have blackouts so
your electric rates are already higher
because of the Jones act you could have
blackouts because of the Jones act and
to show how serious this is last year
all six New England Governors Democrat
and Republican alike asked for a waiver
on the Jones act for the winter so they
could get LNG from other sources the
Biden Administration turned that down
but the six Governors thought it was
important enough to ask for a waiver so
that's just a small example of how the
Jones act cost everyone in New England a
lot of money and could lead to
blackouts chair recognize representative
kry thank you Mr
Speaker I unfortunately uh cannot agree
with a not to pass and I'll tell you why
and I'll make it simple there are sort
of three points that are important to me
and I realized we just had a discussion
about the national impact of the Jones
act which which requires us to buy
americanmade American crude and American
owned
ships because of National Security
concerns which were detailed in the
original um act in 1920 which is still
in force today but I'm going to look at
how this impacts New Hampshire because
I'm a New Hampshire state representative
I'm not a congressional representative
in New Hampshire
although this creates 650,000 jobs
Nationwide in New Hampshire it creates
1,210 jobs these are good paying jobs
people can afford to buy homes and raise
families on these jobs secondly it
provides us with uh border
security as you know having only
americanmade American-owned American
crew ships in our Inland Waters that
provides us with a level of security and
at breakfast today I had breakfast with
a couple of folks from our Public Safety
here in New Hampshire and they said
given our current environment they would
not
change the Jones
act and
finally it provides tax dollars and
Industry to us and that's important too
New Hampshire maid is important and I
think if we learn nothing during covid
we learn the importance of making things
here at
home so Mr Speaker I would ask you to
stand up with me for New Hampshire jobs
New Hampshire made and a strong New
Hampshire border thank you Mr
Speaker Jan as representative Dan
McGuire thank you Mr
Speaker so we've heard bit that that
this Jones act creates jobs or protects
jobs well there's there's no trick in
using the law to create and protect jobs
if you're willing to force people to be
inefficient in what they what they
do for
example um suppose I was to ban
excavators that would create a huge
number of jobs for guys with
s
right so the Jones Act is the same thing
we ban shiers from using their equipment
as efficiently as it could be used from
using their ships a simple example
suppose a ship is is coming from Japan
with with um uh containers goes to Los
Angeles goes to San Francisco goes to
Seattle goes back to Japan because of
the Jones act when that ship drops off
containers in Los Angeles it's not
allowed to pick up a container that's
going to San Francisco so it has to go
partially empty to San Francisco it has
to go even more empty to Seattle and
then go back to
Japan right that empty chip is
inefficient um we heard that there there
are jobs in New Hampshire I I really
doubt that almost all Jones act ships
are tugboats and riverg goinging
ships right no large container ships
none of none of that sort of thing is
built in the United States anymore of
the
600 uh liquefied natural gas ships that
that we and New England need for our
heat and our
electricity none of them have been built
in the United States and no natural gas
ship has been built in the unit United
States for 40
years only about
three um oceangoing uh ships are built
under the Jones act every year and of
the three shipyards that build them two
are foreign
owned I mean it's just silly
um all
right
uh econom IST from the organization for
economic cooperation and development
these are very well-respected economists
the
oecd predict that ending the Jones
act would increase US economic input e
economic output by
$135 billion dollar a
year so this is not minor stuff all
right uh that includes a 71% increase in
commercial ship
building all right um as the
representative uh mentioned this is not
a partisan
issue all the governors of New England
three Democrats three Republicans wrote
a letter to Energy Secretary
grolm two 18 months ago asking for a
suspension of the Jones
act um to bring us more natural gas for
our upcoming
winter let's stand with those
governors with
Alaska whose Governor is required by law
to Lobby Congress against the Jones
act with Puerto Rico who required a
suspension of the Jones act um after
their hurricane so that they could get
resupplied with
Hawaii where a container going from Los
Angeles to Hawaii cost 10 times more in
shipping than a container going from Los
Angeles to
Singapore and most of all with the
residents and our constituents of New
Hampshire who rely on oil gas for their
Heating and for their electricity and
who pay much much higher prices than the
rest of the United
States thank you Mr
Speaker repr represent of Mofford has
asked for a roll call as that officially
seconded is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
seats
hey
tresa
the motion before says AO pass on
hr19 chair recognizes rep this be a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative shirli for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that having a
strong American ship building
requirement and a strong us Merchant
Marine is important to our country's
economy but even more important to our
country's National
Defense and Mr Speaker if I know the
Jones act creates 1,200 Jobs Here in the
granted state that put $72 million into
our state economy and Mr Speaker if I
ever need to remind myself the
importance of American ship building to
this state all I need to do is look at
our state flag and see the friger
Raleigh in the docks in Portsmouth would
I now push the red button so another
motion could be made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recogniz representative
Morford for a parliamentary
inquiring thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that in part due to
the Jones
act which is a protectionist measure
that precludes competition that domestic
ship building has become expensive and
slow and if I know that our non-defense
oceangoing vessel fleet has subsequently
declined from around 200 ships in
2000 to less than 100 ships
today and that our US Navy has declined
from around 400 ships to only 280 ships
today while the red Chinese army or as
you were while the red Chinese Navy now
has around 500 ships and if I know that
competition breeds Improvement and
excellence and that a revitalized ship
building is industry would create not
lose it would create not lose jobs and
finally if I know that the Jones act
makes fuel
and other products more expensive here
in New England would I then press the
green button to support this resolution
calling for the repeal of this 100y old
protectionist anachronism thank you Mr
Speaker motion before is aut to pass on
hr19 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
e all members president had an
opportunity to vote houseold attend the
state of the
vote 165 voting a 180 voting nay the
autop pass motion
fails for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker stage
motion I'd Move itl Motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on hr19 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay
the eyes have it and the motion of
inexpedient to legislate is
adopted excuse this is the last bill
which is for what reason does a member
rise having voted on the prevailing side
I'd like to move reconsideration on hcr1
and urge the body to vote
no okay the motion before us is
reconsideration on hr19
H
hcr1
okay okay the motion before us is
hcr1 is
reconsideration this is a division
vote
motion before us is reconsideration on
hcr1 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're poll you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 186 voting a
156 boy I'm glad we're almost done
um 187 voting aay reconsideration fails
now we're back to committee on
legislative Administration to which was
referred House Bill 1152 act enabling
the mental health flag to be flown at
the State House having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate of John sers for the
committee chair recognizes
representative
McAn
thank you Mr Speaker uh this is the
first time I've pulled a bill from
consent so uh I appreciate everybody's
Indulgence it's late so I'll be brief uh
hb152 would add the mental health flag
to the statutory list of flags that
could be flown at the State House at the
discretion of legislative leadership
last year folks working in the Mental
Health Community reached out to me to
ask if the mental health flag could be
flown at the State House on the 1st of
May to kick off mental health month when
I told them that the flag could not be
flown because it was not on the statuto
list of authorized Flags they responded
by asking me if I could file this bill
to add it to the list the bill was itl
in committee due to logistic concerns
and concerns that if we Grant statutory
approval then it might open the door to
a flood of similar requests and this is
not the only flag bill that was ited um
a bill recognizing the honor and
Remembrance flag was also rejected for
similar reason and it turns out that the
committee deals with a lot of flag bills
all the time and usually rejects them
for the reasons that I just mentioned um
and while both these bills did not get
the favorable recommendation in
committee I spoken to the chair and the
ranking member of the committee and they
feel that it's worth studying rather
than saying no all the time um they
agree that there has to be a workable
way that we as a legislature can
evaluate groups such as Gold Star
Mothers veterans and members of the
Mental Health Community to see if they
are worthy of recognition by this
legislature and how to tangibly express
that recognition so I'd like to give
them the opportunity to do that study I
would therefore ask my colleagues to
vote no on the itl motion so that a
motion of interim study can be brought
forward and we can hopefully find a path
forward to recognizing worthy groups
within our committee uh Community uh
thank you Mr Speaker chair recognized
representative
hunt you recognize representative
hunt Okay um so uh uh as some of you
might know I'm now U chairman of the
history history Committee of the State
House and the flag issue and what would
happen the flag poll came to me and say
how can we solve the problem of who
should have the flags there and really
the resolution is that unfortunately the
the right way to do this is to bring
this bill through the legislative
process and that's why you have it here
um we would like to find a way so that
we can find more places for these flags
to fly uh and there's this is not the
only one there's a lot of them but it's
this point in time I would urge you to
support the committee's
recommendation the motion before us is
any speaking to legisl and House Bill
1152 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
no the eyes have it and committee report
is
adopted representative a
motion for what reason does a member
rise
HCR thank you I would like to um
recommend that we put
the
speech of hcr1 in the permanent
Journal
remarks you move putting the remarks of
hcr1 permanent
journ without
objection
from chair recognizes a member from
Auburn resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered the third reading be read
a third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Thursday February
22nd at 9:00 a.m.
we're almost finished so will everybody
just please stay in your seats for
another couple minutes there's no
unanimous
consent the question is on a third
reading motion are you are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the motion is
adopted chair recognize representative
wer for an
announcement brother Masons brother
Masons members of the of the general
court Lodge let's go have something to
eat at the uh Masonic building on on uh
Iron Works Road right after this I'll
see you there thank you chair recognize
as the clerk thank you Mr Speaker this
is a notice for all of you next week is
a deadline day on Thursday we have over
40 bills on the regular calendar for
next week uh that is in one day so we
will be starting if you didn't hear at
9:00 next Thursday please be prepared to
stay as long as it takes to finish the
bills thank
you representative Osborne moves at the
house stand and recess for the purpose
of introduction of bills and Road bills
amendments enroll bills report vacate
motions and receiveing messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppose nay eyes have
it the motion is adopted the house is in
resets until Thursday February 22 at 900
a.m.